Nice!
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja, und dann geht er hier direkt los, direkt Prime Subscription.
Kleines Stück für den Sub.
Wilder Igel.
Excellent.
Ist ja cool.
Ich muss gerade noch ein paar Sachen einstellen.
nicht direkt für den stream aber ich habe den anderen rechner so selten an
also habe ich ja nur die stream so oder manchmal oder manchmal wenn ich
irgendwas im zweiten bildschirm gucken will
egal kann ich da herrmann
Oh Leute, ich habe meine Pillen noch nicht genommen.
Sekunde.
Ne, vergesse ich die immer.
Gerade mal Wasser einschenken und dann eine Runde.
Pillenstelz.
Excellent.
So.
Erledigt.
Also benutze zwei Windows-PCs und ein Linux-mini-PC mit einer Captcha-Card.
Exakt.
So sieht es aus.
Beziehungsweise ich habe zwei Windows-PCs
Nämlich meinen alten und den neuen
Die stehen halt nebeneinander, ich rotiere das immer so durch
Wenn ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufe
Dann wird jetzt mein aktueller Rechner halt zum Stream-Vorschau-Rechner
Und umgedreht
Wird immer so durchrotated
Alle paar Jahre
Und für Linux-Kram
Habe ich immer einen Linux-Mini-PC
Hast du auf den zwei Windows-PCs auch
Desk-Cloud oder einfach zwei Tastatur-Mäuse?
Ne, da habe ich
Da habe ich
Maus
Maus without borders
habe ich da.
Ja.
Oh nein, Keyleague.
Da habe ich Maus without borders
zwischen den Windows-Kisten.
Wie viel DDR5 ist im alten?
Gar kein DDR5.
Da ist, kann ich dir sagen,
also wir wollen kurz gucken,
Performance Memory 32 Gig,
Speed 3200
Megahertz, das ist noch DDR4, ne
Ja, das ist 32 Gig DDR4
Ey, wisst ihr eigentlich
Was für ein Glück ich hab, dass ich damals
Als ich mir diesen Rechner hier gebaut hab
Auch nicht, mein Rechner war schon schweineteuer damals, ne
Dass ich damals
64 Gig hier eingebaut hab
Wisst ihr, was der Scheiß heute gekostet hätte?
Das wär heute teurer gewesen als mein ganzer
Echner wahrscheinlich.
Danke schön, Max, für den Sub.
51 Jahre.
Exzellent.
Massive Flex.
Ist das überhaupt das Richtige?
Lass uns mal kurz gucken.
Ja.
Ich hab das Ding schon wieder 4 Jahre fast, ne?
Kommt mir gar nicht zu.
Es ist so krass.
Ich hab das schon, glaube ich, 100.000 Mal.
Ich weiß, Recycle Story.
Ich hab das schon 100.000 Mal erzählt.
Aber das hätte es früher nicht gegeben, Leute.
Das hätte es früher nicht gegeben, dass ein PC, der vier Jahre alt ist,
vor vier Jahren quasi so ziemlich das Beste war, was man sich kaufen konnte,
immer noch High-End ist.
Immer noch.
Vier Jahre später.
Das hätte es nicht gegeben.
Früher musstest du deinen Rechner nach zwei Jahren in die Tonne kloppen,
weil du ihn für nichts mehr verwenden konntest.
Das ist doch krass, oder?
High-End-Rechner von 2022, Mitte 2026, immer noch top.
Immer noch eines der besten Hardware-Setups.
Ja klar, in einzelnen Teilen könnte es besser, es könnte eine 5090 sein.
So viel macht es jetzt auch nicht aus, gerade nicht bei 1080p.
Es könnte auch ein bisschen neuere CPU sein.
So viel macht es jetzt aber auch nicht aus.
Es könnte ein bisschen schnellere SSD sein.
Ja.
Länger als, äh, drei Jahre war früher, also wenn wir mal so reden von, sagen wir mal von 1995 bis, wann kam Far Cry 1 raus?
2005 oder so?
Ne, da war ja schon Crysis am Start, 2004.
Also sagen wir mal
Sagen wir mal von 1995 bis 2010
Höchstens
Sagen wir mal 2010, okay
Also diese 15 Jahre
Nach zwei Jahren war dein Rechner im Arsch
Also jetzt nicht Hardware-technisch, dass er kaputt war oder so
Du konntest ihn nicht mehr gescheit benutzen
Ich weiß noch genau
Ich hatte damals einen Rechner mit einer GeForce 3 Grafikkarte
War das glaube ich
GeForce 3 und
einem...
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung. Was für eine CPU hatte man
so in dem Dreh, als GeForce 3 Grafikkarten
angesagt waren?
Ich weiß nicht. Zumindest...
Zumindest wollte ich damals Far Cry spielen
und ich konnte Far Cry wirklich nur
in niedrigen Settings und die Texturen ein bisschen
hochgestellt spielen, weil
mein Rechner zu schwach war. Und der war damals, glaube ich,
eineinhalb Jahre alt. Ja, Far Cry war
halt auch so ein Hammer-Teil damals, ne?
Aber trotzdem, Alter.
WTF? Und heute habe ich
einen Rechner, der ist fast vier Jahre alt
und ich kann immer noch alles Neue in hoher Auflösung
mit 200 FPS
spielen.
Und ist immer noch besser als 90%
aller anderen Desktop-PCs. Nach vier Jahren.
Ja doch, doch so zwischen 2.000 und 3.000
Mark hat man damals bezahlt
für einen Rechner oder später so irgendwie
was um 2.000
Euro, 1.500 Euro,
2.000 Euro.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, ich hab damals im Mediamarkt, also das waren die
Zeiten als ich tatsächlich noch im Mediamarkt Sachen gekauft hab, die hatten im Mediamarkt
damals ein super Angebot für nen Pentium II, 400 MHz und irgendeine billige ATI Grafikkarte,
egal. Dann habe ich eine TNT 1 da reingehauen.
Das dürfte
so 1998 in dem Dreh gewesen sein.
Da habe ich
da eine TNT 1 reingehauen
und hatte einen Pentium 2 400.
Das war richtig krasser High-End-Rechner
damals.
Damals hattest du noch...
Damals konntest du noch
Grafikkarten, High-End-Grafikkarten
konntest du
damals noch passiv kühlen.
Das wäre
Das wäre heute eher nicht mehr drin.
Aber dafür ist es auch egal.
Sogar damals musste man darauf achten,
dass man halbwegs gescheiten Airflow hatte.
Oh man, das ist die 3er.
Die 1er.
Ne, ne.
Die NT1.
Ja, doch hier.
Er ist ja Eraser 2, war es genau.
Ja, die sind passiv gekühlt.
Natürlich VGA-Ausgang und sonst was.
du hast das Video letztens gesehen, ja genau genau genau genau
und man brauchte keinen extra Stromschluss. Ja die Grafik hatten damals, die waren ja noch
das war ja noch nicht PCI Express
das war noch AGP hieß das
Accelerated Graphics Port stand das glaube ich
AGP
Das war quasi der Vorgänger von PCI Express 16.
Für Grafikkarten-Stills.
Wann hattest du die erste Wasserkühlung?
Ende 2022.
Ich habe gerade überlegt, ob ich vorher irgendwann mal damit rum experimentiert habe, aber fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
Den Rechner, den ich jetzt gerade habe
Ist der erste Rechner mit Wasserkühlung
Mit so einer All-in-One-Wasserkühlung
Früher war das ja übelste Wissenschaft für sich
Mittlerweile gibt es diese All-in-One-Dinger
Die schraubst du rein, pappst das Ding auf die CPU
Und gut ist
Ich konnte mir mal ein anderes Gedudel anmachen
Exzellent, viel entspannter
Ja, aber das ist mein erster Rechner mit Wasserkühlung jetzt
es gab ja damals total abgedrehte Sachen.
Ich weiß noch, die hatten damals bei
Toms Hardware?
Gab es eine Seite mal, die sich Toms Hardware nannte?
Ja, genau.
Genau.
Also wir reden jetzt von
2002 oder irgendwie sowas.
Und die hatten damals ein
ultra
dummen Bauvorschlag.
Und zwar
Und zwar den PC in Öl zu tunken.
Also dann noch lieber Wasserkühlung, oder?
Ey, äh, mein...
Was hatte ich davor für einen...
Warte mal, lass dich mal kurz überlegen.
Jetzt habe ich einen 13.900K.
Was hatte ich denn davor für einen Rechner?
Einen 7.070K?
Oder irgendwie so 7.700K?
Oder 8.700K?
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Zumindest...
Den Rechner davor...
Da habe ich auch...
Den habe ich auch geköpft.
mit also damals ich glaube 8700 k war das
na ja genau so ein ding so und intel hat damals so eine richtig dumme idee und
zwar hier sieht man sich als intel hatte damals so eine richtig dumme idee und
zwar haben die den hitsprecher hier oben das ding drauf haben die intern anstatt
Anstatt das zu verlöten, ich bin mir jetzt nicht mehr ganz sicher, ob es wirklich die CPU war, aber ich glaube schon.
Anstatt das intern zu verlöten, also quasi die Oberseite von der CPU mit dem Heatspreader, um halt so optimale Wärmeleitung und Heatspreaden zu ermöglichen,
hatten die intern Wärmeleitpaste dazwischen gepappt, um irgendwie einen halben Cent pro High-End-CPU zu sparen.
Und das hat teilweise 10-15 Grad Unterschied gemacht zu dem, was du rausholen konntest.
So und ich hab damals
Ich hab das sogar auf
Genau, genau
Ich hab das sogar aufgenommen damals
Das ist nicht mein Video jetzt, beides
Ich hab das Video damals von
Wo ich das geköpft hab, nie veröffentlicht, ja
Zumindest konnte man damals
Ich hoffe, man sieht das jetzt hier richtig
Ja
Genau, hier, hier zeigt das
Guck
Du hast dann
Ich hatte
Das ist vom Bauer, das Tool, glaube ich
Das hatte ich nicht
Ich hatte so ein anderes Tool
Zumindest hast du die CPU damals da reingelegt
Äh, ja
Ja, hast du die CPU da reingelegt
Also wie gesagt, mein Tool hat ein bisschen anders funktioniert
Aber von der Idee her kommt es aufs gleiche raus
So, und dann hast du jetzt den Imbusschlüssel genommen gleich
Ich hoffe, er nimmt jetzt einen Akkuschrauber oder so
Genau
So, und dann hast du jetzt so lange
Da dran gedreht, bis es gemacht hat
Knack, ich hoffe man hört das
Ne, da hat Musik, hört man nicht
Bis es gemacht hat, knack
Und wenn es knack gemacht hat
Dann ist intern, da ist so eine
Silikonpaste drumrum gewesen, mit der das
festgeklebt war und die ist dann halt abgerissen.
Und danach hattest du...
Danach
konntest du den Heatspreader von der CPU
abmachen.
Ein bisschen gefuddel.
Und hier siehst du es,
die Intel hat es damals nicht
gelötet, weil wenn das gelötet wäre, könntest du das
jetzt nicht einfach abmachen, sondern hatte intern
auch nur Wärmeleitpaste drauf.
So, und was man dann gemacht hat, ich denke mal,
das zeigt er jetzt auch, was man dann
gemacht hat ist, ich spule mal
ein bisschen vor, dann hat man das Ding erstmal
sauber gemacht von der ekligen Wärmeleitpaste.
Wupptoss,
ich glaube, das haben wir nicht was mit Toss schon.
Jemonkatoss haben wir nur.
Kein Wupptoss.
Gleich machen.
Jetzt müssen wir das mal sauber machen, genau.
Dann, ja, konnte man, wusste man nicht unbedingt, war aber natürlich sinnvoll, weil das ein bisschen dünner war.
Die Silikonpaste runterkratzen.
Ey, da habe ich, ach guck mal, der zeigt das gar nicht.
Da habe ich echt geschwitzt bei, diese Silikonpaste von der CPU runterzukriegen.
Der ist natürlich hart drauf, der macht das mit dem Teppichmesser.
Ich habe mich nicht getraut, mit dem Teppichmesser auf meiner CPU rumzuschaben.
Ich weiß nicht, Chad, hättet ihr das gemacht? Hättet ihr mit dem Teppichmesser auf eurer CPU rumgeschart?
Man muss dazu sagen, die CPU, ich hatte einen der ersten 8700K CPUs in, ich würde fast sagen, in ganz Deutschland, Alter.
Ich hatte wirklich mega Glück damals beim Bestellen.
und hätte ich meine CPU kaputt gemacht, hätte ich erstmal die nächsten 8 Wochen oder so keine CPU mehr bekommen.
Das wäre halt echt Kacke gewesen, ja.
Also da habe ich wirklich enorm geschwitzt.
Ich habe das versucht mit einer Kreditkarte abzukratzen.
Das ging so mehr schlecht als recht.
Aber es ging dann halbwegs.
So und jetzt
Jetzt kommt da so eine flüssig
Metall Ligierung drauf
Die eine deutlich bessere Wärmeleitung hat
Als
Diese Wärmeleitpaste von Intel
Jetzt sieht man nix
Achso
Was er da jetzt macht verstehe ich nicht
Das ist zu advanced für mich
Warum, warum, Chad, warum hat er da, warum hat er da jetzt ein Fleck drauf gemacht?
Übrigens ist das eine richtig clevere Idee mit der Unterlage hier, das habe ich nicht gemacht
So, jetzt wird nochmal kurz sauber gemacht
Jetzt kommt Flüssigmetall drauf, genau
danach gibt es dann
so ein Wattestäbchen
wo man das verteilt
da muss übrigens überhaupt nicht viel drauf
das verteilt sich ja dann ganz gut
flüssigmetall
jetzt muss man das verteilen mit diesem Wattestäbchen
also Leute
Da habe ich wirklich geschwitzt bei, als ich das gemacht habe.
So, jetzt wird das Flüssigmetall oben drauf verteilt.
So, und jetzt, und jetzt kommt es, jetzt kommt es.
Also, jetzt gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten.
So, jetzt gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder man macht den Heatspreader wieder drauf.
und macht darauf dann den kühlkörper oder was die ganz hardcore leute gemacht
haben die den es auf jedes grad angekommen ist die haben den kühlkörper
direkt hier drauf gemacht das problem dabei ist wenn du hier auch nur den hauch
eines millimeters den kram falsch an ziehst dann machst du dein cpu kaputt
das ist wirklich nicht ohne
deswegen ich habe damals keine direct die kühlung gemacht ich bin mir
eigentlich relativ sicher ich habe den spieler wieder drauf gemacht
genau genau genau genau so ungefähr habe ich das auch gemacht
jetzt wird er wieder drauf
das habe ich nicht gemacht was er jetzt macht das festkleben meine meine cpu ist
meine cpu ist komplett lose immer noch da habe ich mich einfach mal auf den anpressdruck vom
Kühler verlassen.
Genau, und du musstest drauf achten,
nee, aus Kupfer, oder?
War das Problem nicht? Also es gibt
ein Problem. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, ob es ein Kühlkörper
aus Alu oder Kupfer war.
Die
haben reagiert und sind gerostet
quasi mit diesem Flüssigmetall zusammen.
Deswegen muss man gucken, dass man den richtigen
Kühlkörper hat, wenn man das macht.
Das hat richtig was gebracht. 15 Grad
oder irgendwie sowas. Haben wir das nicht sogar
damals im Stream ausprobiert?
Chat.
Nee.
Opf.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich bilde mir ein.
Also das hat richtig, das hat wirklich massiv
was gebracht. Das hat massiv
was gebracht. Das war, war es für sich 10, 15 Grad kühler.
Das war wirklich eines der krassesten Hardware-Hacks in dieser Zeit, was man so machen konnte.
Also es hat richtig was gebracht und es hat halt auch nicht wirklich was gekostet.
Das Einzige, was war, wenn du nicht aufgepasst hast, hast du halt 400, 500 Euro CPU geschrottet.
Ach, der hat noch so eine extra Silikonpaste jetzt, um das wieder...
Okay, das habe ich nicht gemacht.
Das ist aber gar nicht so blöd, das wieder zuzukleben mit Silikonpaste.
Weil, wenn die CPU...
Die sitzt ja schräg normalerweise im PC, ne?
Also hochkant, hochkant, nicht schräg.
Hochkant im PC und das heißt, es fällt dir sonst zur Not hier der Heatspreader runter.
Das habe ich nicht gemacht.
Das wäre aber nicht schlecht gewesen.
Ja, es war eine Frechheit von Intel, dass es nicht verlötet war.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Zumal es ja absolutes High-End-Ding war, ne?
Ja, was der Tropfen da macht, verstehe ich auch nicht.
So, und jetzt muss das anpressen für, keine Ahnung, 10 Minuten oder so.
Genau.
Ja, und dann hast du eine geköpfte CPU.
Also da habe ich echt geschwitzt bei.
Also ich glaube ich habe davor und danach noch nie wieder so beim Basteln an Hardware
geschwitzt wie bei dieser CPU.
Bei mir sah das mehr oder weniger auch so aus wie bei ihm.
So.
Oh das gibt es jetzt als extra Bild.
So, dann machen wir doch jetzt mal
Machen wir mal den Lelungs-PC an
Dass wir in unsere normale Aufwachen-Stream-Routine übergehen können
Zack
Achso, Deskflow starten noch, wenn nicht verkehrt
Achso, Chat, während der Rechner hier startet, habt ihr das mitbekommen, dass Nvidia jetzt, anstatt Grafikkarten herzustellen in bezahlbarem Rahmen, Grafikkarten auf Papier druckt, die man sich kaufen kann?
So als Sammlerkarten-Edition.
Wie gesagt, das ist ja eine coole Idee
Es ist, ja, ja
Es ist ja eine coole Idee, aber irgendwie lustig
In der heutigen Zeit
Warte mal, ich kann es euch zeigen
Wartet mal, Firefox
Wenn es dann irgendwann mal startet
So, hier, Firefox
Ja
Guck gibt es von Nvidia jetzt
MonkaS
Du kriegst jetzt von Nvidia
Alte Grafikkarten als
Papierausdruck
Eigentlich irgendwie witzig, ne?
In Zeiten,
in Zeiten, wo du halt keine Grafikkarte
kaufen kannst, kannst du jetzt Papierausdrucker kaufen.
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal ganz wichtig
update.
Oh ne, jetzt macht... Warum macht dieses Ding beim
updaten jedes Mal
so einen Mirror-Test? Das ist komplett
unsinnig. Das reicht,
wenn er das einmal im Monat oder so macht.
Dento Rocks, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscriptions.
Nee, ich finde die Idee gar nicht schlecht.
Ich finde das eigentlich eine ganz coole Idee.
Ich finde es halt nur lustig
in der aktuellen Zeit, dass du dir halt
gar keine echte Grafikkarte kaufen könntest.
So, selbst wenn du willst.
Okay, doch, du könntest,
wenn du 5000 Euro ausgibst. Das stimmt nicht ganz,
was ich gesagt habe. Du könntest schon,
wenn du 5000 Euro ausgeben willst
oder was auch immer eine aktuelle 5090 kostet.
Und die Frage ist, wann es denn endlich
5090 Nachfolger dann gibt.
Auch schon ein bisschen überfällig, glaube ich.
Jetzt machen wir erstmal Update.
Und dann machen wir ganz wichtig...
What?
Chat, mein Update ist kaputt.
Was?
Libdex.
Was zum Teufel ist Libdex?
Dex.
Program to generate and execute desktop entry files.
Libdex.
Library supporting deferred execution.
Kann man das...
aninstallen?
Bazaar?
Bazaar brauchst du eh nicht.
Yes.
So, und jetzt können wir nochmal updaten.
Und jetzt rankt er wieder in Mirrors.
Leck mich, Alter.
Ich mach Pac-Man-Update direkt.
Yes.
Es gibt ein Video, wo du erklärst, wie du den VM-Stack da auf deinem PC so nahtlos hast.
Bei mir ist das immer fricklich.
Ja, fast jeder Stream.
Aber ich kann es dir nochmal im Schnelldurchgang erklären, während Updates laufen.
Also, ist ganz einfach.
Ganz einfach.
Und zwar, ich habe einen Windows-Desktop-PC.
Und einen Linux-Mini-PC.
Okay, das sind die zwei verschiedene.
Was du hier siehst, ist mein Windows-Desktop-PC und was du hier siehst, ist mein Linux-Mini-PC.
Was ich jetzt gemacht habe, ist folgendes.
Ich habe zwei Desktops unter Windows am Start.
Erster Desktop, den ihr hier seht, und zweiter Windows-Desktop ist die Linux-Kiste.
Funktioniert folgendermaßen, ich zeig dir das jetzt mal ohne Magic
Wenn ich hier auf den zweiten Desktop wechsle und Escape drücke, lande ich in einem OBS
Zweiter Desktop ist ein OBS im Fullscreen
Und der Linux Mini PC geht an eine Elgato Capture Card, die 240 FPS supportet
PCI Express Karte ist das
Das heißt, es ist nahezu latency free, wie du das capturen kannst
Wir haben es mal gemessen mit so einem Reaction-Test
Ich glaube wir hatten 15 Millisekunden Verzögerung zwischen Windows und Linux
Also 15 Millisekunden, ich würde damit jetzt keine Competitive Shooter spielen oder so
Aber für Linux-Desktops sind 15 Millisekunden durchaus verkraftbar
Genau, und das habe ich hier einfach im Fullscreen
Und jetzt habe ich ein Makro, mit dem ich umschalten kann
Zwischen dem ersten Desktop und dem zweiten Desktop
so und jetzt fragst du dich wahrscheinlich wie das mit maus wie
viele physische monitore hast du also hier habe ich einen das ist alles auf
dem gleichen monitor hier und hier nebendran auf der linken seite habe ich
noch ein stehen am stream vorschau rechner also ich habe zwei so guck wenn
ich hier rüber rüber switche hier habe ich des flow laufen des flow ist eine
software zur maus und tastatur scheren und ich schere einfach meine maus und
Tastatur von Windows mit Linux. Das ist im Prinzip sowas wie Synergy früher.
So, und in Deskflow, du siehst hier auch, noch bin ich nicht unter Linux, noch habe ich hier
meine Windows-Maus. In Deskflow
habe ich einen Shortcut, wie ich die Desktop switchen kann mit Maus und Tastatur.
Guck, wenn ich das drücke, zack, bin ich hier unter Linux. Wenn ich das wieder
zurückdrecke, zack, bin ich hier unter Windows. So, und was ich mir jetzt gemacht habe,
ist, ich habe mir in meiner Logitech-Software ein Makro
eingerichtet.
Ich habe mir ein Makro eingerichtet.
Ja, Moment, wir sind noch nicht fertig.
So, ich habe mir ein Makro eingerichtet. Nehmen wir mal das Makro,
um auf Linux umzuschalten.
Ich drücke linke
Windows-Taste, Control und Pfeiltaste
nach rechts. Das ist
der Shortcut unter Windows,
virtuelle Desktops zu switchen.
Und dann drücke ich
Alt-A.
Das ist der Shortcut in
Deskflow, um rüber
zu switchen auf Linux. Das heißt,
im Endeffekt, was jetzt passiert ist, das Makro
drückt so und drückt dann für mich
Ctrl-A und ich bin unter Linux.
Und wenn ich dann wieder F1 drücke, macht es
das umgedrehte Zurückswitchen und Desktop
Zurückswitchen. Deswegen sieht das
so nahtlos... Aber du siehst, es ist
nicht ganz perfekt. Du siehst, es laggt
ein bisschen. Siehst du das hier beim Umschalten, wenn du
drauf achtest? Der Mauszeiger
ist beim Umschalten kurz noch da und switcht dann
erst. Siehst du? Wenn ich
bewege, siehst du es besonders.
Die Einrichtung, das geht schnell.
Das ist doch überhaupt kein großer Akt.
Es hat ein bisschen gedauert,
bis ich auf die Idee gekommen bin, das so zu machen.
Wieso kein VNC?
VNC ist...
Also gerade...
Also...
VNC ist okay,
wenn du
Remote irgendwie
einen GUI bedienen musst,
für
irgendein Storage-System oder sowas,
dann ist VNC
okay. Ja, wenn du
240 Hertz
capturen willst, mit
3D-beschleunigten Desktop und allem,
ist VNC
kacke.
Das ist laggy,
das, also
ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich hab's
damit erst gar nicht ausprobiert,
weil meine bisherigen Erfahrungen
sowohl mit RDP
als auch mit VNC
halt so waren, dass das
null an Native Desktop Experience
so rankommt.
Ja, wenn du mit ein bisschen
mehr Gelagge leben kannst und vielleicht nicht
240 Hertz flüssiges Wobbly Windows,
dann kannst du bestimmt noch mit VNC leben.
Äh, Chat?
Wird das Arch User-Repo gerade wieder gedodost?
Kann das sein?
Ist da gerade wieder irgendwas am Laufen?
Was ist das?
Light HTML.
Warum habe ich das installiert?
Chat, wer von euch war es?
Gebt es zu.
Warum habe ich Light HTML installiert?
Ich glaube, das Arch User Repo wird gerade wieder gededost.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Omega keck.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich das aninstalle?
Qt 6 Tools.
das darf ich an installen okay aber jetzt hat keine updates was das angeht machen wir
noch jetbrain idee updates und dann mal gibt es gibt es keine de dos oder so was news
anscheinend nicht.
Zumindest haben die gerade Probleme.
Könnte aber auch an Vodafone liegen, ne?
Also.
The winner.
Synology vs. Ukraine.
Ja, da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Synology ist für...
Das gucken wir dann nur...
Wir skippen da nur drüber.
Für mich ist halt der Vorteil
bei Synology, die Software,
wenn man dieses Gesamtsoftware-Paket haben will.
Dafür bezahlst du bei Synology richtig Kohle für uralte Hardware.
Also insofern bin ich eher für Ugreen oder meinetwegen auch Minisforum
und dann was selbst drauf installieren, wenn man das will.
Wenn man das Komplettpaket von Synology will, dann muss man die Synology-NAS kaufen.
Oder man setzt sich mit Xpinology oder wie das Ding heißt auseinander
wo man die Synology Software auf andere Hardware installieren kann.
Wobei ich da echt nicht sagen kann, wie stable das ist.
Ich habe das ein paar mal ausprobiert mit nicht so geilen Ergebnissen.
Ja, ist auch nichts gegen einzuwenden, Robin, weil man sagt, man will das Komplettpaket haben mit der Synology Software.
Wenn man eigentlich überhaupt nicht auf die fertige NAS-Software in irgendeiner Art und Weise scharf ist, dann kann man sich da selbst Proxmox oder Unraid oder irgendwas drauf installieren.
Man kann auch einfach selbst ZFS auf einer Debian-Kiste machen.
Wenn man eine Hardware hat mit einer Nicht-Abwrack-Netzwerkkarte, so wie das Minisforum NAS.
Ja, aber für Samba-Freigaben kannst du ja auch sowas wie Unrate oder Open Media Vault oder...
Wie heißt dieses andere Ding, was mir nicht gefallen hat?
Trunas und so Gedöns verwenden. Da gibt es ja Möglichkeiten.
Und auf der anderen Seite, ja, Samba-Config ist eklig.
Man muss sich auch mal fragen, wie oft richtet man Samba-Config ein?
Also das machst du einmal und dann fünf Jahre nichts mehr.
Aber das stimmt schon, Samba-Config ist hochgradig abartig.
So, Reboot.
Chatge, ich war gestern 12,7 Kilometer Rennen.
Das habe ich morgens um kurz vor 8 Uhr angefangen, weil es sonst so heiß geworden wäre.
Und ich muss echt sagen, die neuen Schuhe sind mega nice für solche Sachen.
Also ich bin richtig, richtig gehypt.
Da jetzt rennen zu gehen mit denen, das macht richtig Bock.
Das kann ich gleich zeigen
Erstmal hier neu starten
Also ich hab ja zwei Paar Schuhe
By the way, ich hab letztens
Ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen
Da ging es darum
Wie viele Laufschuhe braucht man
So
Chat, Chat, was meint ihr, was die gesagt haben
Wie viele
Laufschuhe braucht man
Also man muss dazu sagen, das war ein Video
Das war ein Video von einem Laden, der Schuhe verkauft
Ne, also
Jetzt könnt ihr euch überlegen, wie viel bare Münze ihr das nehmt, was die erzählen.
Fünf, drei.
Die haben gesagt, man soll so viele Laufschuhe haben, wie man Tage die Woche trainiert.
Das heißt, wenn ihr sechs Tage die Woche rennen geht, solltet ihr sechs verschiedene Laufschuhe haben.
Wenn ihr quasi sieben, acht Tage am Stück lauft, dann mal Pause macht, dann solltet ihr sieben oder acht haben.
Also so, dass du quasi deine Füße möglichst viel trainierst mit unterschiedlichen Schuhen.
Das Ding ist halt, das ist etwas abgehoben, so für die meisten Leute.
Ich meine, es hat schon Sinn gemacht, was der erzählt hat, aber so viele würde ich nicht.
Also ich habe zwei, ja, ich habe zwei Schuhe zum Laufen.
Ich habe einmal einen super weichen, gedämpften, wo du das Gefühl hast, du läufst auf Marshmallows.
Das ist aber halt richtig gut, wenn du deine Beine ausruhen willst, wenn du es eh schon im Schienbein merkst, willst aber trotzdem mal eine halbe Stunde oder 40 Minuten deine Runde drehen, ohne dein Bein übermäßig zu belasten.
So, da habe ich ein Paar.
Und jetzt habe ich ein neues Paar.
Es ist kein Sellout. Ich kriege von Asics kein Geld oder so.
Ich kann euch dazu sagen, was ich will.
So, also ich habe zwei Sortenschuhe.
Ich habe einmal...
...das Ding.
Wir gehen jetzt mal bei Asics auf der US-Seite gucken.
Was mich bei Asics bei der Webseite mega abfuckt, ist...
Ich weiß immer hier unten nicht, wie man das umschaltet.
Ich will Englisch, die Originalseite haben.
So, Men, Schuhe.
Running Shoes.
So, also.
Ich habe einmal die hier.
Ich zeige euch auch, ich zeige euch auch, warum.
Oh, den gibt es keiner mehr. Kann das sein?
Ja.
Also ich habe einmal den hier.
Ich zeige euch das jetzt absichtlich hier.
Ich habe den aber, glaube ich, so sieht er aus.
So sieht er aus.
Also ich habe einmal den hier. Mit dem habe ich angefangen.
Ich finde, das ist der beste...
Ey, ohne Scheiß, es ist nicht so, als hätte ich 500 Schuhe ausprobiert, ja.
Also ich habe viel dazu gelesen und meine Füße sind eher breit als hoch, ja.
Also ich finde, das ist der beste Einstiegslaufschuh, weil das Ding ist super gedämpft.
Wie gesagt, ihr seht ja die Sohle hier.
Das heißt, du hast ein bisschen das Gefühl, du läufst auf Marshmallows, so beschreibe ich das mal, oder auf Watte.
Marshmallows trifft aber besser.
Der hat den Vorteil, in der Regel Leute, die neu anfangen, die sind noch nicht sonderlich trainiert,
die sind vielleicht auch ein bisschen schwerer und bei denen ist weder Schienbein, noch Wade, noch Muskel sonderlich trainiert.
Gelenke sind auch noch nicht so drauf aus, da so viele Stöße zu bekommen.
Als Einstiegs- und ich bin froh, dass ich mir den als Einstiegsschuh damals gekauft habe.
Gut, nicht der 28, damals habe ich mir einen 25 oder irgendwie sowas gekauft.
weil das Ding gibt es
in Standardweit,
Extraweit und in allen Größen.
Ihr könnt das halt ohne Probleme auch in Deutschland
kaufen, bei Amazon oder so.
Das ist halt super flexibel.
Ihr könnt da genau den Schuh
kaufen, der zu eurem Fuß und eurer Größe,
zu eurem Gewicht und sowas passt.
Also für den Einstieg
finde ich das super und ihr könnt zum Einstieg
auch alles damit rennen. Das ist überhaupt
kein Problem. Ihr könnt damit ein bisschen
schneller rennen, ein bisschen langsamer,
lang, kurz, überhaupt kein Problem.
Also zum Einstieg, finde ich, ist das der
bestes Schuh gewesen.
Weil es halt schonend ist.
Weil es bringt euch ja nichts,
wenn ihr anfangt zu rennen
und voll motiviert seid
und nach dreimal Rennen
tut euch so das Schienbein
oder irgendwas anderes im Fuß weh,
dass ihr wieder eine Woche Pause machen müsst.
Das hat ja keinen Sinn.
Also ihr müsst am Anfang
eh gucken, dass ihr nicht so schnell rennt,
vor allem, dass ihr nicht so lange
und auch nicht so oft rennt, sodass sich
erstmal alles an Gelenken,
Waden, Schienbein, Füße,
Muskel und so dran gewöhnen können.
Sonst könnt ihr es vergessen, sonst tut es euch
weh nach drei Tagen.
Da ist der Schuh halt super für.
Ihr seht, was der für eine hohe
Schaumstoffsohle hat.
Es ist ein bisschen wie,
mal gucken, ob es ein YouTube-Video für gibt.
wenn ihr auf... Schauen wir mal.
Ich hoffe,
der zeigt auch, wie er da mal ein bisschen
drauf drückt oder so.
Weil aktuell...
Geil!
Geiles Review, ohne dass man zeigt,
wie man damit läuft. Perfekt.
Gut, das ist...
Es gibt auch eine
Frauenvariante.
Most comfy
shoe of the year.
Ich hoffe, man sieht halt auch mal, wie er läuft damit.
Weil... Hier.
Moment. Guckt mal hier. Seht ihr das?
Guckt euch mal die...
Guckt euch mal das Schaumstoff unten an.
Seht ihr das?
Wie sich das zusammentrückt? Also das ist super
weich.
Und zum Einstieg ist es perfekt.
Also das ist wirklich...
Ihr habt das Gefühl, ihr lauft so auf Marshmallows.
Was der Schuh halt
nicht macht, ist
Energie wieder abgeben
nach vorne.
Das heißt, ihr braucht
in diesen Schuhen mehr Energie zum Schnelllaufen
wie mit anderen Schuhen.
Was euch aber gerade am Anfang
so für das erste halbe Jahr
oder so, überhaupt nicht
stören sollte.
Du kannst damit zwar auch schneller laufen, aber du brauchst
auf jeden Fall mehr Energie, wie mit
einem Schuh, der ein bisschen mehr responsive
ist. Das Ding absorbiert halt
so ziemlich alles, was es an Stößen
gibt nach unten, aber nicht mehr nach oben.
Beziehungsweise nicht mehr nach vorne.
Aber es gibt für mich keinen besseren
besseren Schuh, den ich anhatte
für
mein Bein zu schonen.
Der Schuh hat Input-Lag.
Okino kann ich gleich was zu sagen.
Der Schuh hat quasi Input-Lag.
Ja. So. Und was ich mir jetzt noch
gekauft habe, ist, weil ich gemerkt habe,
ich werde
immer schneller. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ja. Und
mir ist genau das, was ich eben
beschrieben habe, aufgefallen,
du steckst halt sehr viel Energie
in diesen Schuh rein, beim
Aufsetzen, der Schuh gibt aber kaum
Energie ab.
Das heißt, ab einer gewissen Geschwindigkeit
fühlt sich das
fühlt sich das an, als bremst
dich was, ja? So als
kommst du einfach nicht richtig vorwärts.
Du kannst ohne Probleme mit dem Schuh
schneller rennen, aber es ist halt
anstrengender und du merkst, dass du jedes
Mal ein bisschen mehr in den Schuh drücken musst,
dass du wieder nach vorne kommst.
So, und deswegen, also
ohne Scheiß, Max, das für mich
ist das der beste
Starterschuh, weil du kriegst
den in allen Weiten, also selbst wenn du
einen super breiten Fuß hast, kannst
du den in extra Weiten, alle Größe, alle Weiten.
Das ist der beste Einstiegsschuh und das erste
halbe Jahr braucht man auch nichts
anderes und selbst danach ist es
nicht verschenkt, weil
weil auch wenn du ein bisschen fortgeschrittener bist und dir vielleicht noch ein bisschen schnelleren Schuh kaufst,
oder wenn du es dann irgendwann mal so machst wie in dem anderen Video, 6,5 Schuhe im Durchschnitt oder sowas, die gesagt haben,
selbst dann kannst du den immer noch gut gebrauchen, nämlich wenn du mal dein Bein schonen willst,
wenn du irgendwelche Recovery-Läufe machst oder wenn du einfach nur sagst, ey, heute sind 12 Kilometer dran oder eineinhalb Stunden dran,
ich will mal mein Bein ein bisschen schonen, dann ziehst du das Ding an, also den hast du nie umsonst gekauft.
So, was ich jetzt halt gemacht habe, ist noch zusätzlich, weil ich das gemerkt habe, das fühlt sich an, wenn du mit dem, sagen wir mal so, sobald du einen Pace von so 6,30 easy laufen kannst und wenn du anfängst, dass du jetzt eigentlich schneller laufen möchtest, dass deine Fitness auch zulässt, dann merkst du das, bei jeder Pace Erhöhung ist das ein bisschen so,
als hält dich einer so ein bisschen
fest, als
wirst du ein bisschen gebremst. Dadurch,
dass die Energie halt, ihr seht ja wie fett
diese Schaumstoffsohle ist, dass halt
so viel Energie beim Aufsetzen
in die Sohle, also in diesen
Schaumstoff reingeht, gedämpft wird,
aber halt nicht mehr nach oben abgegeben wird.
Zumindest habe ich das gemerkt, ja.
Als ich angefangen habe, so
ungefähr 6,30er Pace easy laufen
zu können, also auch
ähm, also auch
die großen Runden, ja,
12, 13, 14 Kilometer
so im Durchschnitt 6,30, 6,25
habe ich irgendwie gemerkt, ey, das bremst.
Ja, so geil ist das nicht.
So, und was ich mir jetzt noch gekauft habe, ich habe mir so
einen Allrounder-Schuh gekauft von
Essex und zwar einen
Tja, wenn man eine Webseite
gescheit sucht, Superblast
So ein Ding hier.
Ich habe ja ein Foto von ihm gepostet.
Ich habe Asics Superplast gekauft.
Das ist einer, der ist dafür gedacht, dass du mit dem alles machen kannst.
Der ist gedämpft, hat aber auch nochmal so einen Zwischenschaumstoff.
Kann mir mal einer erklären, was gerade mit meinem Browser abgeht?
Ihr seht das im Stream gar nicht richtig, oder?
Hier oben ploppt die ganze Zeit auf, dass Essex meine Location drauf zugreifen möchte.
Keine Ahnung.
Sieht man, ja.
So, und das Schöne bei dem ist, und deswegen, das macht mir richtig Bock.
Ich bin damit jetzt schon dreimal oder so gelaufen.
Das macht mir richtig Bock, weil das Ding ist leicht as fuck.
und das ist viel, das ist viel, wie soll man sagen, viel mehr reactive.
Also wenn du da auftrittst mit, geht einiges der Energie natürlich hier noch in die Sohle und wird gedämpft,
aber der ist viel mehr responsive und ergibt auch mehr Energie ab.
Also wenn ich damit jetzt schneller laufe, habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass mich irgendwas festhält.
Ja, Rackman, jeder Fuß ist ein bisschen anders
So, aber das in Kombination finde ich halt richtig geil
Weil mit dem kannst du lange Strecken langsam laufen
Du kannst schnellere Sachen laufen
Überhaupt kein Ding
Und die anderen, die ich euch vorher gezeigt habe
Die benutze ich auch, wenn ich meine Beine mal ausruhen will
So
Und das macht richtig Bock mit dem Ding zu rennen
Also den kann ich echt empfehlen.
Das ist so ein Rundum-Ding.
Gibt sogar Leute, habe ich auf YouTube Videos gesehen,
die sind schon Marathon damit gelaufen.
Jetzt sind Ultra Competitive vorne mit dabei.
Ja, die Leute haben irgendwelche
Carbon-Platten drin und so.
Wobei das auch nicht so gesund ist.
Zumindest sollte man das nicht jeden Tag machen.
Aber wie gesagt,
die zwei Dinger kann ich echt empfehlen.
Das ist
sehr pog.
So, und auf die Frage hier vorhin.
Wo ist er denn?
Bin gerade erst reingekommen, als auch wenn schon gesagt wurde.
Aber wie hast du mit dem Laufe angefangen?
Nach einem speziellen Plan oder nach gut Dünken?
Also, angefangen habe ich irgendwann.
2023 oder so.
Irgendwie so.
In dem Dreh.
Ich habe aber einen Fehler, also irgendwie Mitte 2023 oder sowas habe ich angefangen
Ich habe aber den Fehler gemacht
Das ist, was heißt Fehler?
Fehler würde ich es jetzt nicht unbedingt nennen
Ich hatte ein paar psychische Probleme in der Zwischenzeit
Wo ich nicht sonderlich motiviert war, laufen zu gehen
So, das heißt, ich habe zweimal längere Pause gemacht von so einem halben Jahr und in einem halben Jahr verliert man halt massig Trainingsprogress.
Aber nachdem ich jetzt ja Pillen nehme und nachdem es übrigens wieder weniger und nachdem es mir jetzt auch insgesamt deutlich besser geht,
habe ich seit Anfang des Jahres wieder angefangen.
Ja, immer, immer im Winter, immer, ganz jahrelber.
Und habe ich seit Anfang des Jahres wieder angefangen und es geht steil bergauf wieder.
Und wie ich angefangen habe, war tatsächlich erstmal so eine spontane Sache.
Okay, du bist überhaupt noch da?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt eine halbe Stunde erzähle, du bist schon wieder weg.
Also, wie ich angefangen habe, war so eine spontane Sache.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, was mich damals geritten hat.
Entweder habe ich ein YouTube-Video geguckt.
Oder ich habe irgendeine Sportsendung im Fernsehen geguckt.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest habe ich mir überlegt, Max, du bist zwar viel zu fett.
Und du bist nicht trainiert.
Aber guck doch mal, wie weit du rennen kannst.
Und da habe ich mir meine ganz normalen Alltagsschuhe angezogen.
Das sind welche gewesen, wirklich mit steinharter Sohle, dünn, die waren überhaupt nichts zum Rennen.
Da habe ich gesagt, okay, guck mal einfach, wie weit du kommst.
Und da bin ich dann, so von jetzt auf gleich, weil es mir danach war, bin ich mal losgerannt.
So, und ich bin, ich weiß nicht, also ich hatte keine Uhr oder irgendwas, ich habe auch nicht gecheckt, wie schnell ich gelaufen bin, nix, ja.
Und da bin ich, glaube ich, ich weiß es nicht, wie weit ich gekommen bin.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, weißt du was ich, eineinhalb Kilometer, zwei Kilometer, eineinhalb Kilometer, irgendwie sowas, ja.
Also weder sonderlich schnell, noch sonderlich weit.
Aber irgendwie
Hab ich mir danach gedacht
Ey Max
Das war ja viel besser als erwartet
Ja, also ich hab wahrscheinlich gedacht
Ich bin nach 200 Meter
Im Arsch
Also, muss dazu sagen
Wenn ich vom Bahnhof heimlaufe
Da muss ich
Je nachdem wo ich laufe
Über 1-2 Bahnübergänge
und ihr kennt das ja vielleicht, wenn ihr auf den Bahnübergang zulauft und die Ampel am Bahnübergang springt um,
dann rennt ihr noch ein Stück los, um noch über die Schranke drüber zu kommen, obwohl es schon rot ist.
Und ich habe gemerkt, dass ich zu Zeiten, wo ich noch 108,5 Kilo gewogen habe und über den Bahnübergang gesprintet bin,
dann war ich quasi eine Viertelstunde später immer noch kaputt von, keine Ahnung, 80 Meter Sprint oder so.
Und irgendwie habe ich mir dann gedacht, ey, hast du nicht ein super teures Fahrrad gekauft?
Na, so teuer war das auch nicht. Fahrrad habe ich am Start, ja.
Na, zumindest daraufhin habe ich mir dann irgendwann gedacht, so, nachdem ich dann auch, glaube ich, einen Beitrag gesehen habe auf YouTube oder so,
jetzt fängst du an und erstes Mal gelaufen, so.
So, und da habe ich dann gesehen, ey Max, das war doch viel besser als erwartet.
Und das war der Moment, wo ich gesagt habe, ich fange jetzt einfach an, regelmäßig zu laufen.
Also dieses, Max, das war doch jetzt schon besser als erwartet.
Und wie gut ist das denn erst, wenn man dann anfängt, das regelmäßig zu machen,
hat dann dazu geführt, dass ich erstmal die erste Woche komplett planlos einfach losgerannt bin.
ja, viel zu
schnell in den falschen Schuhen
und sonst wie, da hat mir super
das Schienbein weh getan, weil ich halt in so
Kackschuhen gelaufen bin und alles
sondern irgendwann habe ich mir so gedacht, ey so
der Weisheitsletzter Schluss ist es ja
nicht
und dann habe ich im Internet mal
ein bisschen geguckt
und dann bin ich relativ schnell
drauf gekommen, okay, man braucht
gescheite Schuhe
und so nach dem ersten Monat Laufen
habe ich mir dann
die Schuhe gekauft, die ich euch eben gezeigt habe.
Hier diese Dinger.
Allerdings damals irgendwie den, keine Ahnung, 25er oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, so ein Ding habe ich mir damals gekauft.
So ein Teil hier.
Und das war schon gleich viel besser zu laufen.
Und im gleichen Zuge habe ich mir noch eine Garmin-Uhr gekauft,
um zu gucken, wie schnell ich bin.
und mit der Garmin Uhr bin ich dann drauf gekommen, dass man sich ja über die Garmin App auch Trainingspläne generieren lassen kann.
Und seitdem laufe ich nach dem Garmin Trainingsplan.
Ich habe jetzt die Uhr leider nicht hier und mein Handy auch nicht, sonst könnte ich euch das nicht...
Warte mal, ich hole das einfach.
Kann ich das kurz vorlesen?
So.
Wieder am Start.
Also.
Das Generated Ein- und Trainingsplan
anhand
Das ist halt das Gute an der Garmin-Uhr.
Das kann das anhand deiner aktuellen Belastung anpassen.
Wie gut du geschlafen hast, wenn du die nachts anziehst, die Uhr.
Was du sonst noch für andere Sportarten machst,
da kannst du den Trainingsplan ein bisschen anpassen.
Deswegen finde ich das besser als irgendeinen statischen Trainingsplan von einer App,
die keinen Zugriff auf deine Gesundheit oder gar ein PDF aus dem Internet.
Die keinen Zugriff auf deine Werte hat.
Was ich mir auch noch angeguckt habe, war Runner App.
Aber die wollten mir direkt ein Abo aufschwätzen.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, da bleibe ich lieber bei dem Garmin Trainingsplan.
So, also was da jetzt angesagt ist.
Gestern, kann ich euch sagen, war 1 Stunde 20 Long Run.
12,7 Kilometer ungefähr bin ich gestern gerannt.
Langsam, ich glaube 6, 18er Pace.
So, also.
Trainingsplan, was ist dran?
Heute ist 6.25er Pace, 45 Minuten Basis, oder wie nennt man das auf Deutsch?
Grundlagen Ausdauer dran.
So, morgen ist Rest Day.
Dann ist am Dienstag 5.10er Pace, 42 Minuten lang.
Allerdings 3x6 Minuten mit Ein- und Auslaufen, also jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit.
Mittwoch ist wieder 6,25,31 Minuten Base
Dann ist Donnerstag wieder 19 Minuten at 5,15
Freitag ist wieder 42 Minuten Base
Samstag ist wieder 6,25er Pace Long Run
Also der variiert das dann ein bisschen, sodass man optimale Auslastung hat
Von niedrigem Pulsbereich, mittlerem Pulsbereich und ab und zu mal Sprints
Und ich muss sagen, ich komme mit dem Garmin Trainingsplan echt super klar. Also man hat meistens so, nachdem man das, am Anfang, ja am Anfang ist das Ding auch clever, am Anfang macht das, wenn ihr neu anfangt, macht das erstmal eine halbe Stunde, dann Tag Pause, eine halbe Stunde, dann Tag Pause.
Mittlerweile ist es so, ich habe meistens 6-7 Tage am Stück Training.
Manchmal sind es 6 Tage Recovery, nochmal ein bisschen was schnelleres und dann noch ein Resttag.
Also so 6-7 Tage am Stück und dann ist ein Tag Pause.
Und dann wieder 6-7 Tage am Stück und dann ist wieder ein Tag Pause.
Aber je nachdem, was meine Garmin-Uhr da so denkt anhand der Performance-Werte.
Und damit komme ich super klar.
Also, das ist das Beste, was ich machen konnte.
Ich bin jetzt mit 42 Jahren so fit, wie ich noch nie gewesen bin.
So sieht es aus.
Also ja, ich mache das nach einem spezifischen Plan.
Könntest du mal die Garm in den Linken?
Den Linken kann ich von hier aus nicht, weil...
Meine Uhr gibt es nicht mehr.
Da gibt es einen Nachfolger.
Muss mal gucken, was der Nachfolger ist.
Linken kann ich nicht, weil...
Ich bin hier eingeloggt.
In dem Chat hier.
Ich habe eine Garmin Forerunner 255S.
Die muss es aber auch nicht sein.
Es reicht auch die 55S.
Beziehungsweise die jetzt dementsprechende Uhr.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, was die Einstiegsuhr ist aktuell von Garmin.
Lass uns gerade mal gucken.
Laufen.
Die haben ja auch unübersichtliches Lineup.
Es fuckt bei Garmin.
Machen wir hier Einsteiger.
Alter, wie beschissen kann eine Webseite sein?
Zum Shop?
Alter, Garmin, was ist das?
Ah, 70 heißt die jetzt.
Ne, das ist nicht U-Block Garmin.
Okay, ich glaube, die 70...
Kann man jetzt nicht einfach sagen?
70 ist jetzt, glaube ich, die...
Die aktuelle Einstiegslauf...
Ja, ja, übertreibt halt mal!
1.300 Euro!
Die taktische Multisport...
Ulti-Sport. Was ist denn an der so
taktisch? Ist das wie bei Amazon, wenn du
dir irgendwas kaufst, sobald es Tactical ist,
kostet es extra Kohle.
Ich hab bei Amazon
mir einen Spaten gekauft,
für den Garten. Spaten.
Und
da gab es...
Amazon.
Spaten.
So ein Ding
hier hab ich mir gekauft.
So, und
so ganz billigen hier, irgendwie für 25 Euro.
So, und das Witzige
war, wenn man
da einfach nur nach Spaten sucht,
bei Amazon, Moment,
ich such jetzt mal, Spaten
Tactical,
da findet man auch Spaten,
die Tactical sind, die kosten aber
gleich das Dreifache, haben irgendwie
eine komische Säge noch nebendran.
Also sobald da, sobald da,
sobald da, guck hier, hier,
sobald da Tactical dran steht, kostet es das Dreifache.
Tactical, das ist ja Tactical-Sparten, ja.
Und das ist anscheinend ja auch so, sobald es Tactical ist, kostet das dreimal mehr.
Also ich glaube, das hier scheint die Einstiegs-Uhr aktuell zu sein von denen.
470. Das reicht zum Einstieg locker aus.
Und die Akkulaufzeit ist halt geil im Vergleich zu einer Apple Watch.
Man muss das eh pairen mit der App.
Ohne App sagt das...
Naja.
So schaut's aus.
Äh, Ali, das macht auch coole Laufschuhe.
Du kannst dir ein paar YouTube-Review-Videos angucken.
Am besten ist natürlich,
falls du irgendeinen Laden bei dir in der Nähe hast,
wo du die ausprobieren kannst, mal auf dem Laufband.
Aber ihr wisst halt, wie sadge das ist.
Es gibt kaum Läden.
Und wenn es Läden gibt, sind es halt irgendwelche Kackläden,
die sich drüber beschweren.
Hilfe, Einzelhandel stirbt, bei mir kauft keiner was.
Und wenn du dann fragst, was habt ihr denn für Dämpfungsschuhe,
dann haben die ein Modell von 2023 da für 400 Euro.
Und das kannst du halt vergessen.
Wenn du ein Laufband, also ich weiß nicht, ob du die Möglichkeit hast,
ein bisschen längere Strecken indoor zu laufen, irgendwo.
Oder ein Laufband irgendwo hast, vielleicht im Fitnessstudio, keine Ahnung.
Da kannst du nämlich die Schuhe bestellen und wieder zurückschicken.
Was du halt nicht machen kannst ist, wobei, bei Amazon kannst du das machen.
Amazon kontrolliert die zurückgeschickten Sachen ja eh nicht.
Aber in der Regel kannst du nicht mit ein paar Schuhe draußen laufen gehen und danach sagen, passt nicht gut, ich schicke die wieder zurück.
Bei Amazon wahrscheinlich schon, weil Amazon schmeißt den Kram eh auf den Müll und interessiert sich nicht, was in der Packung ist.
Aber bei Amazon musst du ja auch aufpassen.
Du kannst bei Amazon nicht von 10 bestellten Sachen 8 zurückschicken.
Irgendwann haben die auch keinen Bock mehr.
Die Gadget Bridge.
Was zum Teufel ist die Gadget Bridge?
Lass uns doch mal gucken.
Achso.
Gadget Bridge.
Garmin Watches.
Okay, das ist irgendeine Material Design Webseite.
Die Gadget Bridge.
A free and cloudless replacement for your gadget when those closed source android applications.
Ja, ich habe leider kein Android.
Sad kid.
Aber das Ding ist halt, bei der Garmin App, man braucht übrigens, Garmin möchte einem übrigens auch die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Abos aufschwätzen, braucht man nicht.
Bei der Garmin App ist es halt so, du hast da noch ein paar Services dabei, die du halt mit einer normalen App...
Wahrscheinlich nicht kriegst, wie beispielsweise diese Trainingsplangenerierung und sowas.
Also es gibt bei Garmin zwei Trainingsplangenerator.
Einmal welche, die komplett offline, nur mit Uhr und App funktionieren.
Das nennt sich dann täglich Daily Suggestions.
Und dann gibt es Garmin Coach.
Das ist so ein Ding, was irgendwie online die Pläne generiert.
Da müsst ihr natürlich dann auch eure Health-Daten mit Garmin sharen.
Geht beides, ja.
So, wunderbar.
Dann gucken wir doch mal, was auf GitHub so dran ist.
Übrigens, weil ich hier gerade noch Python-Zeug vom letzten Stream, letztes Wochenende offen habe,
ich bin wieder ein bisschen von meinem Python-Gebastel abgerückt,
weil ich zu dem Schluss gekommen bin, Python Self-Contained Applications ist Shit, genauso wie ich es ursprünglich gedacht habe.
Ich habe die Woche über noch zwei, drei Tage lang versucht, ein statisch gelinktes Executable zu bauen,
was auf allen Linux-Systemen läuft.
Das habe ich auch hinbekommen.
das war ein riesenakt da musste ich nämlich live peyton static bauen da habe ich mir extra
alpine container für gebaut dass das funktioniert hat das problem ist sobald du peyton komplett
static gebildet hast kannst du keine module mehr laden was ja logisch ist die erlauben
funzt ja nicht bei also kannst keine shared sachen laden mit einer statisch gelingt das
funktioniert nicht. Zumindest nicht so ohne weiteres.
Das Ding ist aber,
die großen und
beliebten Python-Packages,
die haben fast alle irgendwelche
C-Extensions, die als extra Module
geladen werden wollen.
Und viele Sachen, so wie NumPy,
kannst du gar nicht komplett statisch kompilieren.
Also, kannst du vergessen.
Ist für den Arsch.
So, machen wir das hier alles mal zu.
Rrrrrrrr.
Nee, nee, nicht reboot.
Wollen gar nicht rebooten.
Sag mal, hast du zu Terminal-Emulatoren die liebste Meinung oder ist das jetzt völlig Wurst?
Ja, habe ich.
Westterm beste.
Ich benutze Westterm.
Ich würde auch nichts anderes benutzen wollen, ehrlich gesagt.
Westterm ist beste, aus meiner Sicht.
Das einzige, was an Westterm ein bisschen suckt, ist,
dass sie es irgendwie seit zwei Jahren oder so
nicht hinbekommen,
mal ein neues Release rauszuhauen.
Ein neues Stable Release.
Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Das gibt hier täglich neue,
also das Ding ist super active developed,
aber sie kriegen es irgendwie nicht hin,
ein neues Stable Release rauszuhauen.
Das finde ich ein bisschen schade fürs Projekt an sich,
weil gerade Leute, die neu damit anfangen,
die wollen natürlich, die benutzen halt erstmal das Stable Release
und wenn das Stable Release
irgendwie zweieinhalb Jahre
alt ist, ist es halt auch bis sie
ne, aber Westterm ist
das Beste, das Gute an Westterm ist
also ich hab schon
also Kitty, Kitty
hab ich mir angeguckt, Kitty ist Schrott
aus meiner Sicht
wenn man oft per SSH
unterwegs ist auf Servern
weil der Kitty Maintainer
ist komplett
Anti-Temux-SSH-Usage.
So. Das heißt, da funktioniert
die Health nicht. Oder war zumindest damals so.
Deswegen konnte ich Kitty nicht benutzen.
An sich bestimmt ein nice Terminal.
Ghosty habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Ghosty ist auch dieses Ding, was für irgendwelche KI-Geschichten
gedacht ist. Alakritty hatte
mir damals zu wenige Features.
Letztens habe ich
Rio Term ausprobiert.
Das hat einen vielversprechenden Eindruck
gemacht, hatte aber ein paar Features nicht, die ich gerne
hätte. Und so bin ich mehr oder
weniger bei Westterm
gelandet.
Ja, aber ich will, ganz ehrlich,
ich will meinen Rechner neu starten
können,
wenn ich auf dem Server eingeloggt bin und es läuft
da immer noch weiter. Also für mich ist es essentiell,
dass ich mich ordentlich auf dem Server
SSH'en kann und da Temux aufmachen kann und
damit alles machen und damit hat Kitty ja
irgendwelche Probleme.
So, und da bin ich irgendwie vor Jahren
bin ich bei Westterm gelandet. Westterm ist für mich
das beste Terminal, was es gibt.
Denn
ich habe früher
T-Mux verwendet.
Tja, ich würde mich jetzt gerne mal...
Habe ich nicht.
Hier irgendwie...
Habe ich nicht noch einen Raspberry Pi irgendwie?
55?
Ah, Max ist es.
So.
Also früher hatte ich das so.
Guckt. Ich hatte hier
einen T-Mux auf.
Und dann habe ich mich noch auf den Surfer verbunden.
Und habe da T-Mux gestartet.
Und da hatte ich T-Mux in T-Mux.
Das ist richtig eklig.
Weil dann habt ihr hier einen T-Mux.
Das heißt, Ctrl-B-C startet hier
ein neues Ding. Wenn ihr auf dem Server ein neues Tab
starten wollt, müsst ihr Ctrl-B-B-C
und so drücken.
Kommt mir jetzt keiner mit irgendeinem dummen Witz.
So, das ist
nix Temux in Temux.
Deswegen bin ich irgendwann
bei Westterm gelandet,
weil Westterm kann Splits
wie Temux,
kann vertikale
horizontale Splits wie Temux,
kann zoomen wie T-Mux,
kann Tabs wie T-Mux
und ist besser als T-Mux,
weil man hier Copy-Pasten kann,
ohne das komplette Terminal zu Copy-Pasten.
Das heißt, ich benutze die Splits von Westterm lokal
und wenn ich mich auf den Server verbinde,
gehen wir jetzt mal hier,
dann mache ich auf dem Server T-Mux auf.
Und dann habe ich das Beste aus beiden Welten.
Auf dem Server eine persistente Session mit einem Standard-Tool, was auf allen Kisten installiert ist.
Lokal komme ich mir nicht mit den Shortcuts von Temux in die Quere.
Und so bin ich bei Westterm gelandet.
Der Vorteil von Westterm, was es sonst noch hat, ist, dass es rendert.
Es rendert relativ schnell.
Ja, kannst du nichts sagen.
Also, ich habe hier keinen Lag oder irgendwas.
Und was Westerm auch noch richtig gut macht ist, du hast eine Lua-Config.
Du hast eine komplette Programmiersprache in deiner Config-Datei.
Was?
The fuck?
Was zum... Was bin ich hier sehend? Was ist das für ein Emote?
Ja, du hast eine komplette...
Ja, du hast eine komplette Programmiersprache in einer Config.
Und da kannst du zum Beispiel so Dinger machen, wenn dir das Default-Verhalten nicht gefällt.
Ich habe das beispielsweise so eingerichtet.
Das habe ich auch schon hundertmal gezeigt.
Aber ich zeige es nochmal, weil ich es nice finde.
Ich habe das so eingerichtet.
Guck, wenn ich was doppelt anklicke oder wenn ich was markiere.
Wenn ich was markiere im Terminal, dann kann ich mit der rechten Maustaste, ich drücke jetzt die rechte Maustaste, Copy und wieder rechte Maustaste, Paste.
Das ist nicht das Default-Verhalten.
Das habe ich hier selbst in der Config gebastelt, nämlich der guckt, also das ist quasi die Funktion hier, der guckt, hat das eine Selection,
also sprich, ist in diesem Terminal was selected, dann macht rechte Maustaste Copy, also Clipboard and Primary Selection,
das Kopien und danach die Selection Clearen.
Guck hier, zack, rechts.
Und wenn nicht selected ist, dann ist die rechte Maustaste Paste.
Also ich kann jetzt im Endeffekt, wenn ich Copy, Paste will, sage ich jetzt hier,
rechtsklick Copy, rechtsklick Paste.
Die üblichen Sachen von Mittelklick und so funktionieren natürlich weiterhin.
Aber das sind halt Sachen, wenn du eine komplette Programmiersprache in einer Config hast, kannst du so Dinger configuraten.
Was sehr nice ist.
So sieht's aus.
Ja, der Kitty-Maintainer meint, Temux ist ein Anti-Pattern.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was mit dem Kitty-Maintainer da los ist in der Richtung.
Ja, wenn du es nur bei dir lokal verwendest, kann man das sicherlich besser machen.
Aber sobald du es auf dem Server brauchst über SSH, gibt es da wenig Alternativen, meiner Meinung nach.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass für den alles andere, was in Richtung Temux geht, auch ein Anti-Pattern ist.
Den Friseur gibt es noch, ja
Der hat sogar letztens ein Video hochgeladen
Vor zwei Wochen oder so
Ne, das habe ich mal ausprobiert
Das hat mir nicht gefallen
Das Maushandling und so
Fand ich da richtig eklig
Ich habe ja auch jegliches Maushandling
In T-Mox ausgeschaltet
Ne, ne, das hat mir nicht
hat mir auf den ersten Blick nicht zugesagt.
Aber für mich ist das eh das Beste,
was du haben kannst, ja?
Western macht das ganze Fenster
und Pain Handling.
Und Temux
auf dem Server, fertig.
Da brauchst du ja sowas wie Celli J
und den ganzen Krempel gar nicht.
Ich wüsste jetzt ehrlich gesagt
auch gar nicht, was es für Vorteile bieten würde.
Einzigen Vorteil, den ich sehe bei Temux Lokal oder Cellij Lokal ist, ich kann mein Terminal abschießen und die Session wäre danach noch da.
Wobei ich glaube, das geht mit Westterm sogar auch irgendwie.
Aber nachdem mein Terminal nie crasht Lokal, habe ich da jetzt keinen Anwendungszweck.
Mir ist das Terminal glaube ich nicht einmal gecrasht.
Warum sollte das auch crashen?
Es ist written in Rust.
Das kann doch gar nicht crashen.
Hast du schon mal Terminator probiert?
Ja, habe ich auf der Arbeit.
Auf der Arbeit benutze ich Terminator.
Weil Westterm
da nicht gescheit funzt.
ich benutze ja auf der Arbeit eine Linux-Kiste,
auf der ich Admin-Rechte habe,
Root-Rechte habe, und
X-Forwarde mir dann
einen Terminal im Fullscreen.
Und das mache ich mit Terminator, weil das
wenig Lag hat,
gut funktioniert über X-Forwarding und Westterm
nicht richtig. Da habe ich übrigens die gleiche
Belegung wie in meinem Westterm, also hier ein neues
Tab, Splits und so.
Ist Terminator nicht antik? Das kann schon
sein, aber es funktioniert ganz gut.
Puh.
So.
Nein, das war nicht.
Dann lass uns doch mal gucken, was aktuell auf GitHub so trendet.
Shit Hub.
Was macht eigentlich GitHub?
Status.
93,29% Uptime.
Leute, ganz ehrlich.
Wenn meine Services auf der Arbeit nur 93,29% Uptime hätten, dann wäre ich nicht mehr da.
Das ist dermaßen schlecht.
Also was trendet denn diese Woche?
Zeigt mal her.
AI.
Was?
Ach so, E-Mail.
Ja, okay, hatten wir das letzte Mal schon.
AI.
AI
Fake Muffs
Bestimmt AI
AI
Geil, ist ja diese Woche richtig viel tolles Zeug dabei, was man sich angucken kann
Und Rust.
Komm, wir gucken mal.
Wir gucken mal.
Nee, komm. Wir schauen mal, was...
Doch, Rust. Komm, wir schauen mal, was bei Rust trendet.
Ob da irgendwas Neues dabei ist.
Rust.
AI.
Hat das nicht letztens sogar irgendjemand...
Ist das der VM-Champ?
Ist das der VM-Champ nur in gut?
Easy, fast, local, first, micro, VM, runtime and library.
Mal gucken.
Microsandbox.dev
Microsandbox runs untrusted workloads inside fast and local...
Ach so, das ist irgendwelches Agent-Gedöns wieder.
Aber so blöd ist das doch gar nicht.
Ja, by the way, also ich kann diese Tools eh nicht mehr benutzen.
Ach so, Moment.
Ich kann diese Tools ja wieder benutzen.
Ich bin jetzt ja auf dem Linux-Mini-PC nicht mehr in der VM.
Weil in der VM funktioniert das ja mittlerweile nicht mehr mit Nested-Virtualisierung.
schallt unter Windows, wenn man Windows Features an hat.
Also, was sage ich
jetzt? Wie führst du das? Warte mal.
Boot a
Microwave in a single... Moment, NPX!
Ich soll JavaScript ausführen,
um...
Onkaw.
W.
Gibt es das
vielleicht auch über das Aua?
Ja, ja.
Ich weiß. Ihr werdet gerade gededost.
Geht mir nicht auf...
Ich mach jetzt einfach mit.
Das Aua wird wieder gededost.
Was ist da los?
Mikro Sandbox
Naja
Ähm
Trau ich mich
Trau ich mich das zu installieren
Cargo install Mikro Sandbox
UV Tool install
NPM bestimmt nicht
Was ist denn Irm
Ist das Curl für Windows
Ich werde das jetzt mal ausprobieren
Okay, wir machen es einfach so
Cargo install, Mikro Sandbox
Bam
Oh, ah
Ja, ich weiß warum, weil ich kein Rust-Stells
Mehr hier drauf habe, weil ich nur noch
In Container-Kram entwickle
Dann können wir doch
Alter, mach hin
Oh.
Bin ich jetzt IP-banned?
Pac-Man.
Minus S.
Was? Cargo? Ging das so?
Ich kann gar keine Pac-Man-Commands mehr.
MonkaS.
Rust.
Warum gibt es hier 30 Milliarden
extra Pakete? Kann ich einfach
Rust installieren?
Rust?
Aber da ist das Cargo nicht dabei, oder?
Oder ist Cargo
dabei? Ah, jetzt ist Cargo dabei.
Okay. Cargo install Mikro
Sandbox.
Was?
Mach das jetzt.
Alter, das halbe Internet.
Es downloadet das halbe Internet.
Okay, ich bin Supply Chain Angriff wahrscheinlich jetzt.
F, Leute.
RIP.
RIP Rechner.
Jetzt vorbei.
Wait a minute.
Leute, seht ihr das gleiche, was ich auch sehe?
Seht ihr das?
Das ist ja geil.
Guck mal.
Das updatet seine Tab-Description,
je nachdem, wie fortgeschritten er ist.
Das ist ja advanceder Kram.
Alter.
Massive.
Oh, mein Rechner ist ein bisschen ausgelastet gerade.
Quasi Sonnenfinsternis im Terminal, ja.
By the way, warum bin ich eigentlich so dumm?
Es gibt es doch bestimmt als Binary, was ich hier runterladen kann, oder?
Oh, wie man recht schnell ausgelastet ist.
Was sagt eigentlich H-Top so gerade?
Das startet noch nicht mal.
Oh!
Das haut wieder richtig rein.
Volle Puller ausgelastet.
RAM voll.
CPUs voll.
Äh, ist Cargo...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ist Cargo gecrashed?
Nee.
Aber ich könnte es mir einfach auch hier runterladen, oder?
Oder nicht?
DLL?
What?
Hier, da ist es doch.
Linux x86.
Ja, dann.
Dann brechen wir diesen ganzen Krempel hier erstmal wieder ab.
Hier, hier, Repos.
Tools.
Ne, wie habe ich das genannt?
Skripts.
L-Programm, meinetwegen, ja.
Da will das jetzt unbedingt hin.
Okay.
MSB, umgenannt zu MSB.
So, MSB.
Permission denied. Ah ja, ich bin dumm.
CRMOD plus 6, MSB.
So, also, was kann ich jetzt, was kann ich damit jetzt machen?
MSB, Run Debian. Okay.
Geil.
Exzellent.
Lip Grunpf.
Not found.
Und wenn wir da dabei sind, dass Self-Contained Binary eine geile Sache sind.
Hallo.
Arch User Repo.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
AM.
Cargo.
Wir machen das jetzt...
was du bildest das noch mal ich habe gedacht er hätte es jetzt wenigstens
gecached oder so monkaS okay dann mach jetzt mach jetzt mal da können wir
gucken können wir weiter gucken was auf github trendet in der zeit wo das
compilen sort
alternativ könnte ich einfach auch den hier machen so ich will das mal ausprobieren
Das ist tatsächlich mal ein interessantes Projekt hier.
Vielleicht ist ja wirklich der
VM-Champion gut.
So.
Distributed
Durable Objects.
Das habe ich sogar letztens
ein Video drüber gesehen.
Das ist...
Das ist nicht ein
Key-Value-Store für S3 gewesen.
Aber sowas in der Richtung, oder?
Habe ich letztens
ein Video drüber gesehen.
Kann aber sein, dass ich durcheinander bringe.
Ja, mein Rechner ist ein bisschen ausgelastet gerade.
Open CAD Studio.
In Rust.
Bammel.
Oh, please.
Nicht nur ein weiterer Jammel-Dialekt.
Terminal-Based-ID und Texteditor.
Fresh.
Die Rust-Leute, die sind echt ganz hart da drin, schon bestehende Sachen neu zu erfinden.
Machine Learning Powered Manga Translator.
Das war's. Chat.
Das war was für euch, oder?
AI.
G-Pui Component.
AI Rust Desk
Das ist hier für den indischen
Microsoft Gold Support Scammer
Def Env
Nix
Okay, er ist fast fertig, Compile
Das ist halt echt bei Rust krass, ne
Rust Projekte haben
immer hunderttausende
Dependencies
Es ist nicht so schlimm wie NPM.
NPM, beziehungsweise halt generell JavaScript-Projekte, sind da einsamer Spitzenreiter.
So nach dem Motto, über eine Million Downloads von einem Paket, was dafür da ist, um zu checken, ob eine Zahl gerade oder ungerade ist.
Wenn es da nur was in der Sprache Eingebautes gäbe, ne?
Also das ist quasi ein Modulu 2-Wrapper.
Ich zeige das immer gerne, weil mir die Leute nicht glauben, dass es das gibt.
Also das ist ein Package, ein JavaScript Package, das hat 1,3 oder fast 1,4 Millionen Weekly Downloads und ist im Endeffekt ein Wrapper für Modulo 2.
Guck.
Is Even gibt es auch, klar.
Okay, das ist Modulo 2 Wrapper.
Das Package.
Und was noch viel besser ist, guck mal, es gibt tatsächlich auch das Package IsEven.
Ich hoffe mal, das ist vom gleichen Dude.
IsEven ist noch ein viel besseres Package.
Weil
is even
is even hat eine Dependency
auf is odd.
Und is even
is not is odd.
JavaScript Packages.
Keg W.
So, ich glaube, gleich haben wir die Mikro-Sandbox
am Start.
Düdüdü.
Bammel.
Broken Languages for Agents.
Okay.
Es gibt
schon mal kein
Example. Das ist etwas
blöd immer.
Okay, das hat mit Jammer
immer absolut gar nichts zu tun.
Wir haben es, Leute.
Mikro-Sandbox.
Ich hab...
Was ist Mikro?
Modern Intuitive Terminal Text...
Warum hab ich denn das überhaupt installiert?
Öh.
Chat. Fuck, wie kommt man hier wieder raus?
Ich weiß, wie man Wim exited.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie man Mikro exited.
Alt-G?
Mit
Shift-Q.
Warum habe ich das installiert?
Solche Noob-Software brauche ich nicht.
Ah, CacheOS Micro Settings.
Gut, CacheOS hat das vorher vorinstalliert.
Ich bin freigesprochen.
Ich habe nicht irgendwelche Noob-Editors installiert.
Also.
Micro Sandbox Run Debian.
Nice.
Ey, das ist ja noch schneller als der
VM-Champ, Leute.
Massive VM-Champ.
Äh, VM-Champ-Alternative.
Hat das ein
Netzwerk-Stack?
Up-Install-IP-Tools?
Oder was muss man dafür installieren?
Für IP-Tool?
Net-Tool. Net-Tools, oder?
Moment, IP-Tools,
Net-Tools installiert.
Was muss man installieren, um IP zu installieren?
Okay, F-Config
haben wir. F-Config eh besser.
Okay, man hat
Netzwerk-Stells am Start.
Oh, das gefällt mir.
Das gefällt mir echt ganz gut.
Das ist quasi der VM-Champ, nur in gut, oder?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Das heißt, wenn man mal schnell
VMs braucht, um irgendwas auszuprobieren,
zum Beispiel
Kernel-Kram, den man halt nicht in
Docker-Container ausprobieren kann,
dann ist das echt cool.
Was hat das denn für...
Was hat das denn für Command-Line-Arguments?
Also,
Run,
Create,
Modify, hat das eine Completion?
Completion?
Und sogar Shell Completion hat das.
Okay.
Self Update.
Okay, das kann sich sogar updaten.
So, dann gucken wir doch mal.
Completion.
ZSH.
Und dann sourcen wir das mal.
Und gucken wie das aussieht.
Micro Sandbox.
Ah, wahrscheinlich, weil das MSB heißen muss, ne?
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Das guckt, das guckt, das muss MSB heißen.
Das ist natürlich blöd, dass sich das als Mikro-Sandbox installiert,
aber intern MSB genannt werden will.
Das ist schon ein bisschen doof, ne?
nochmal Witch,
Micro Sandbox,
linken wir das jetzt einfach mal,
Micro MSB,
so, und jetzt sollte das eigentlich funktionieren,
jawohl, MSB,
Run,
äh,
also da muss man sagen,
Chat,
der VM Champ,
äh, what,
Der VM-Champ hat eindeutig
ein besseres Autocomplete gehabt.
Der hat dir nämlich auch Images angezeigt.
Moment, das sind Docker-Container?
Das ist schon ein vollständiger VM.
Moment, wir gucken mal,
Ob der uns auch ausgeben kann
Auf Wasser angeblich
Basiert
Abt install
Ich glaub wird, ist es nicht wird what
Doch
Wird what
KVM
Das ist der echte KVM
Also
Der
Das gefällt mir
Weil manchmal, gerade um irgendwie
Körnelmodule Sachen irgendwas auszuprobieren
ist so eine komplette VM nicht schlecht.
Chat, denk mal mit dran,
das nächste Mal, wenn wir wieder eine richtige VM brauchen,
nutzen wir MSB.
Weil der VM-Champ,
der ist ja broken.
Was kann man damit sonst noch so machen?
Übrigens richtig nice das Projekt.
Keine Ahnung, warum das...
Keine Ahnung, warum ich das nicht schon früher entdeckt habe, aber das gefällt mir.
Ach, guck mal, das hat sogar...
Man kann sogar 4Ms in...
quasi andere Programme einbetten.
Ruby!
Ein Ruby-Exempel.
Ja, das gefällt mir.
Das finde ich nice.
Das hat was.
Guck mal, es gibt sogar so eine Art
Sandbox-Kompost.
Ja, das ist ganz nice.
Ich werde es wahrscheinlich nicht hierfür verwenden.
Aber
schnelle
VMs
kann man gebrauchen.
Ab und zu. Braucht man nicht oft. Meistens tun es Container.
Ihr wisst ja, ich entwickle nur noch
in Containern mittlerweile,
um mich gegen Supply Chain Angriffe zu schützen.
Es sei denn, ich muss Cargo Install
auf meinem Hausrechner machen.
Wenn ich was
wenn ich was
develop, developer
dann
funktioniert das bei mir ja so
ich gehe in ein Projekt rein
sag welche IDE ich starten will
und dann
baut er mir einen Container
auf dem ich entwickeln kann
und macht mir eine IDE auf in dem Container
was sehr
angenehm ist und was mich
etwas vor Supply Chain Angriffen schützt
Supply Chain Angriff und Container to Host
Exploit. Container to Host
ist gar nicht so einfach,
wenn vom Host
nichts gemountet ist.
Das ist DevPod.
Ja.
Allerdings nicht der offizielle
DevPod.
Guck, jetzt habe ich hier
mein Projekt.
habe ich meine idee offen und ein container auf dem man entwickeln kann
das ist der sport allerdings nicht das offizielle der sport release weil das
offizielle der sport release ist quasi abandoned
da tut sich nichts mehr es gibt aber einen der sport und zwar
von ski wetter
Der hat einen Devport Fork.
Und der wird aktiv gemaintained.
Der hat auch schon einiges gemacht drinnen.
Und mittlerweile hat er auch gesagt, er hat selbst keinen Bock mehr auf...
Was der KI-Dude hat, der hat auch ein ganz neues Projekt.
Der KI-Dude hat ja auch ein komplett neues Projekt.
Du meinst hier das KI-Bild von ihm
Genau, der hat ein neues Projekt
Wo er DevPod nachbauen will
Mal gucken
Ey, ich bleib erstmal bei DevPod
Der Vorteil ist halt
Wenn man in Containern entwickelt
Man ist nicht ganz so anfällig
Du bist nicht immun gegen Supply Chain Angriffe
Ne
Das nicht, weil das Ding hat immer noch Netzwerk Access
Und sonst was
Hast du schon mal von
Dockers Sandboxes gehört
Das hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert, ne
Docker-Sandboxes
SBX-Run-Claude
Kann ich nicht SBX-Run-Debian machen?
Docker SPX
habe ich das überhaupt installiert?
Ne, habe ich nicht.
SPX
Und gibt es da irgendwie auch
einen
Getting Started oder sowas dazu?
Weil das richtet sich ja
anscheinend hauptsächlich an irgendwelche KI-Geschichten.
Wie sieht das denn aus?
Kann ich sowas machen wie
SBX Run
Debian?
Was ist der beste Weg,
um Arch-User-Repo-Pakete zu laden?
Schaut euch jedes manuell an.
Am besten ist gar nicht.
So viel aus den offiziellen
Repos nehmen, wie möglich.
Wenn es nicht anders geht
und wenn es überschaubare Anzahl ist,
gucke ich mir tatsächlich den Kram an,
bevor ich es installiere oder bevor ich es
upgrade.
Getting started.
Okay, das richtet sich hauptsächlich an
KI-Gedöns.
Ja, ne.
Ist dann Dev-Container auch okay, wegen den Supply Chain Attacks?
Das ist ja Dev-Container.
Dev-Pod ist ja im Endeffekt eine Dev-Container-Implementation.
guck ist based on dev container nur dass du kein wishlist für den mist brauchst
also die idee und der code wird einfach direkt im port entwickelt und die back
ja also das funktioniert folgendermaßen das funktioniert nicht mit allen ideen
das funktioniert mit wir können mal gucken mit was es mit was es funktioniert
mal gucken
ja wie lässt man sich das jetzt an wie lässt man sich das jetzt anzeigen was
das für idees unterstützt idee list
ok also der kann anti gravity bob
Ihr habt mal ne Ahnung, was Bob ist?
IBM Bob
Was?
Okay, whatever, keine Ahnung
Irgendwelches IBM Zeug
Ähm
Codeserver, also Visual Studio Code
In allen Varianten, Cursor, Dataspel
Fleet
Warte mal, ist Fleet überhaupt noch ein Ding?
Haben die Fleet nicht eingestellt?
Oder habe ich das falsch im Kopf?
Fleet is now part of Air.
Gut.
Goland, IntelliJ, Jupiter Notebooks.
Du kannst doch einfach nur einen Container mit Command Line starten.
Da brauchst du gar keine IDE.
VS Code, PHP, Positron.
Keine Ahnung.
Pych, also das ist quasi ein positiv geladenes Elektron.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was das für eine IDE ist.
Pych, Charm, Rider, Air Studio, Ruby Mine, Rust Robber, VS Code.
wind surf z unterstützt das alles die ford ist warum auch immer gold habe ich das mal
als default gesetzt weiß nicht ja und das funktioniert das funktioniert folgendermaßen
der startet also deswegen geht es auch nur mit den ideen die hier die hier zu porten werden also da
startet ein container und lädt darauf quasi das jeweilige remote development back end der
jeweiligen idee runter also du kannst du brauchst zwei sachen du brauchst quasi
so einen so einen backend für die jeweilige idee was in dem container
läuft und dann hast du halt dein container frontend was auf deiner auf
deiner normalen linux kiste läuft also das hier läuft nicht im container das
hier läuft wie ihr seht hier wobbly windows das läuft super schnell und
fast bei mir lokal auf der auf der kiste gar keinen gar kein problem wenn die
Sachen lahm sind, dann liegt es nicht am Container, sondern
daran, dass JetBrains an sich...
Oh, dass JetBrains an sich jetzt
nicht das Schnellste immer ist.
Und das Backend
von der IDE läuft im Container und wird
in dem Fall über JetBrains Gateway
connected.
Und wie kopiert das dann die
Source-Code-Dateien rein? Das macht
ein Mount von dem Verzeichnis, in dem es gerade ist.
Guck.
das hier ist mein Projekt
das ist mein Projekt
und wenn ich mich da rein
verbinde, also was passiert
beim, hier ist ein DevContainer
Ordner, in dem DevContainer
Ordner ist bei mir ein Connectionscript
was im Endeffekt ein bisschen
Magic macht, aber unter der Haube
macht es
DevPodUpOpenIDE
True und schreibt dann da den IDE
Namen rein, im Endeffekt
mehr macht es nicht
Und dann connectet sich noch per SSH in den DevPod rein.
Also das hier ist das eigentlich, was passiert.
Nur, dass ich da so ein Command-Line-Auswahl gemacht habe.
Der connectet sich, also der nimmt quasi das, was in dem aktuellen Ordner ist, wo du das ausführst.
Kann dir das zeigen.
Machen wir jetzt hier nochmal, keine Ahnung, hier links, was wollten wir am Pipe schrauben?
Guck mal, der connectet sich ja hier jetzt auch, der macht eine IDE auf.
connectet sich mit der idee rein er macht aber auch hier nennen eine shell
auf und der unter workspaces maute der automatisch den source code rein
nee der maute das rein du hast zugriff vom container und außerhalb vom
container auf die gleichen dateien das ist ein ganz normaler mount so wie das
doch auch macht so wie wenn du sagst doch aminus v
Blub nach Slash Blub oder so.
Ja, das hat nämlich den Vorteil,
das hat nämlich den Vorteil,
dass du das gleiche Verzeichnis,
machen wir mal kurz hier oben, peitschen wir mal das aus,
du kannst das gleiche Verzeichnis auch
auf dem Host aufmachen
und dort dann zum Beispiel so Sachen
machen wie ein Docker-Bild.
Weil ein Docker-Bild in Docker
geht natürlich nicht, wenn man nicht
Docker gemountet hat in Docker.
Und ich will Docker nicht in Docker mounten, weil wenn ich einen Supply Chain Angriff mal wirklich hätte,
könnte es ja über Docker in Docker gemountet super easy aus dem Container ausbrechen.
Deswegen mache ich hier einfach mal ein Bild auf dem Host und alles andere.
Packages installieren und Gedöns.
Also hier in einem Container auf dem Host und alles andere mache ich hier drin.
Also das ist ein super Kombi. Bin ich sehr happy damit.
Aber da musst du schon ein sehr fettes Repro haben.
Weil ich glaube, wir haben da drin sogar mal den Linux-Kernel aufgemacht.
Das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Ich breche den Bild mal ab.
Hat eh keinen sinnvollen
Mehrwert.
Ich darf den Bild nicht abbrechen.
Das ist zu advanced, mein Bild.
Das juckt es nicht, wenn ich es abbreche.
Schön, dass du wieder am Start bist.
Machen wir doch mal hier.
Linux.
Das dauert jetzt eine Weile.
Chat, ich bin immer...
Gab es nicht CP?
Das geht nur mit AirSync, ne?
CP Progress.
Das geht, glaube ich. Ich glaube, CP kann immer noch keine Progress machen.
Das ist was, was die Gnu-Leute echt mal machen könnten.
Geht nur mit AirSync.
Er hat schon kopiert.
Guck mal, wir haben jetzt sogar
im Container
hier den Linux-Kernel-Source-Code.
Und das ist von der Geschwindigkeit her
überhaupt kein Problem.
Wir können hier gehen nach...
Keine Ahnung, was machen wir dann so für ein Net?
Net.
Realtek.
Ne, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo wir hin müssen.
Hier find, name, Realtek.
Wir müssen zu...
Auf jeden Fall in net.
Realtek, groß geschrieben. Ey, keine Ahnung. RTL?
Okay, ich bin zu dumm, den Realtek-Treiber zu finden.
Ich glaube, das heißt...
1, 6, 9.
Oh shit, jetzt habe ich was kaputt gemacht, Leute
Ah
Oh fuck, was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Ich habe, es war keine gute Idee, dass ich
den Bild abgebrochen habe
Ich glaube, ich habe irgendwas verkackt
Oh no
Leute
Ich glaube, wir haben es geschrottet
Oh, geht's wieder?
Oh, shit.
Das ist komplett im Arsch.
Ich glaube, wir haben uns gerade irgendwas geforkbombt oder so selbst.
Vermutlich.
Ich versuche mal alles zu beenden.
Aber ich kann dir sagen,
das liegt nicht am Linux-Körnel im Container.
Das liegt daran, dass ich diesen Build-Point
gecancelt habe und wahrscheinlich an einer
schlechten Stelle.
Und da jetzt im Hintergrund noch irgendwas läuft.
Oh, guck mal,
die Farbe ist anders geworden.
Mein Terminal hat die Farbe geändert.
Zu viel CPU-Last.
Okay.
Was passiert hier gerade?
Chat, seid ihr das?
Gebt zu.
Gebt zu hier.
Seid ihr schon drin?
Memory shortage avoided.
Okay.
Was zum...
Es war, glaube ich, doch keine so schlaue Idee.
Also Jetbrains macht hier irgendwelches komisches Zeug.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich sage jetzt
DevPod delete
und lösche das Ding mal wieder.
Und dann hoffe ich,
dass sich das alles wieder normalisiert.
Ist das jetzt wieder gut?
Ja.
Noch mal Glück gehabt.
Wie zufrieden bist du mit CacheOS?
Komplett.
Komplett zufrieden.
Aber ich mache damit jetzt eigentlich auch nichts, was ich nicht mit normalen Arch-Dealings machen könnte.
Ich benutze, ich meine, ihr seht das ja, ich benutze mein CacheOS KDE mehr oder weniger wie meinen Tiling-Window-Manager.
mehrere Desktop, Fullscreen
also ich mach damit jetzt eigentlich nix
wofür man unbedingt ein KDE
bräuchte
warum ich ein KDE hab, ist ganz einfach
die Wayland Unterstützung
in VMA Workstation ist halt bodenlos
schlecht
X wird über die nächsten Jahre immer weiter
ausgefaced werden
und
warum dann nicht einfach
ein fertig vorkonfiguriertes
Wayland KDE Setup benutzen
und Shortcuts so anpassen.
KDE ist ja auch super customizable.
Nicht einfach so anpassen,
dass es sich mehr oder weniger wie mein Tiling Window Manager
verhält.
Hab ich jetzt ja.
Und das meiste Tiling mach ich eh
mit meinem Terminal.
Und das geht auch weiterhin.
Also ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Hyperland
und
wie heißt das anderes?
Sway
und Niri.
Niri fand ich in der Tat ganz nett.
Das habe ich mal ausprobiert.
Das hat mir ganz gut gefallen.
Aber das Ding ist halt,
unter Wayland ist es nicht verkehrt,
wenn du einen Desktop verwendest,
der sehr verbreitet ist.
Und wir reden jetzt nicht von Gnome.
Gnome war vorher kacke und ist immer noch kacke.
Weil Wayland ist halt kein X-Server in dem Sinn, dass du oben drauf sitzt, sondern Wayland ist ja nur eine Spezifikation und alle Desktops oder alle Window-Manager implementieren den Kram selbst.
Das heißt, wenn du KDE benutzt, ist die Chance sehr hoch, dass die das meiste implementiert haben.
Und das Wichtigste für mich, weshalb ich kein Hyperland oder irgendwas anderes verwende, wichtigstes Feature, Wobbly Windows.
Und das gibt es nur unter KDE.
Ist das nicht nice?
Wie das wobbelt, das Windows.
Das Beste, oder?
Ihr seht das ja auch nur mit 48 FPS.
Bei euch ruckelt das Fenster.
Ich sehe das mit 240 FPS.
Und das ist das weicheste Windows-Wobbeln,
was ich je gesehen habe.
Ja, es gibt
total viel Zeug, was unter KDE
einstellen kannst ich habe das meiste ausgeschaltet und habe auch also animation habe ich ausguck hier
wird nichts mehr beim workspace switchen ich habe animation aus ich habe irgendwelche trans
transparency effekte aus außer meinem terminal aber das liegt vom terminal selbst ich habe
alles ausgeschaltet und die shortcuts habe ich mehr oder weniger auf das gelegt was ich beim
einem teilen window manager auch hatte was ich unter e3 auch hatte ja also hier quasi
34 desktop durch switchen fenster minimieren maximieren und sowas du schmeißt sofort wieder
runter ja als auch beste entscheidung ob die windows schlägt einfach alles so aber wir wollen
ja noch github ist das zeug fertig gucken also haben wir doch schon mal richtig cooles projekt
gefunden. Also muss ich sagen,
Micro Sandbox
gefällt mir.
Hast du dort auch einen globalen
Fullscreen, also über alle Bildschirme? Ich habe nur einen Bildschirm.
Zweiter Bildschirm ist
an einem zweiten Rechner dran.
Da kann ich hier nichts
über beide Bildschirme spannen.
Ich habe nur einen Bildschirm hier dran.
Der zweite Bildschirm ist hier an meinem Stream-Vorschau-Rechner.
So.
Also das war ein cooles Projekt. Das hat mir gefallen.
Hier.
Micro Sandbox.
Sehr nice.
Werden wir in Zukunft bestimmt ab und zu mal verwenden.
Computer sind ohne Wobbly Windows und Desktop Cube nicht zu benutzen
Gebe ich dir halbrecht, ja
Ich mein, es ist schon ein Witz, ne
Dass Windows keine Wobbly Windows hat
Aber KDE Wobbly Windows hat
Obwohl man ja Wobbly Windows eher von Windows erwarten würde
Als von KDE
Aber Desktop Cube
Bin ich kein Fan von
Was ist KDE?
Ich bin mir nicht mal so wirklich sicher, wofür KDE...
Also KDE ist der Desktop.
Ist das Desktop-Environment hier?
Ich bin mir gerade gar nicht mehr so sicher, für was KDE steht.
Ich weiß nur noch, dass es eine saudumme Abkürzung war.
KDE, Linux, stands for...
Cool.
Cool Desktop Environment.
Das ist so dumm, Alter.
Mittlerweile ist
ganz ehrlich, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo KDE
anfängt und aufhört und Plasma
anfängt und aufhört. Ich nenne es einfach
KDE.
Also, Mikro-Sandbox, sehr nice.
Gefällt mir.
Ja, das ist quasi eine Datenbank für S3-Storage.
Das ist für die High-IQ-Cloud-Native, Leute.
Ist es denn written in Rust?
Natürlich.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob es KI-generated Rust ist.
Schauen wir mal, ob es aussieht wie KI-generated Rust.
Schwer zu sagen.
Ich würde fast drauf tippen,
teilweise KI generiert.
Weil
das ist schon auffällig, viele Kommentare.
Das ist KI.
Das kannst du mir nicht erzählen, dass das nicht KI generiert ist.
Das ist sowas von KI generiert.
Zumindest zum Teil.
Contributors.
Tja, weiß man nicht.
Also die haben weder in den Contributors
Claude drinnen,
noch haben die irgendwelche
irgendwelche Sachen, die darauf hindeuten.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich glaube trotzdem,
dass da vieles KI generiert ist.
Guckt euch mal die Comets an.
Wahrscheinlich hat die KI 800 Comets gemacht
und die haben die jetzt quasi
resettet und gesquasht auf 1.
Ja, wenn da...
Ey, Leute, Leute, ey.
Wenn dieses Comet nicht KI generiert ist,
dann ist nix KI generiert.
Was wird heute nicht mehr mit oder mit Hilfe von KI gemacht?
Die Netzwerkkarte in meinem NAS gefixt.
Da ist auch selbst KI dafür zu dumm.
Wozu braucht man bei S3 Storage noch eine Datenbank?
Ja, wenn du strukturiert auf deine Sachen zugreifen willst und die ordentlich querien möchtest,
aber du nicht viel Geld für dein Storage bezahlen willst.
Schnell ist das mit Sicherheit nicht eine Datenbank auf S3.
Warum es das nicht für .NET gibt?
Okay.
Nur mal eine Frage.
Wir gucken es uns an, okay?
Aber ist es von dir und du willst es promoten?
Ich habe da nichts dagegen.
Ich frage dich nur.
Ist nicht von dir, okay.
Ich glaube dir das.
Spring Flash RP.
Flash RP is coming to the Spring March.
Okay.
Ich checke nicht so wirklich, was es ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ah!
Man legt quasi
ein Datenbank-Model an
und für das Datenbank-Model
erzeugt es dann eine Rest-AP.
Ja gut, kann man machen.
Solange man, solange man,
solange das quasi so eine
stumpfe,
ähm, für was steht
CRUD? Create,
Remove, Update,
Delete, ne, äh, äh, ach, keine Ahnung.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine, ja.
APS, dann ist das wahrscheinlich nicht schlecht.
Read.
Create, Read, Update, Delete.
Genau.
Finde ich eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Ja.
Man muss echt sagen,
ich habe ja früher immer so
so Kappa-mäßig
mich über Java lustig gemacht.
Mir war schon immer klar,
dass Java, also die Plattform
an sich und die Sprache an sich,
bei weitem nicht so kacke ist, wie ich die immer mache.
Und,
dass sie sau verbreitet ist, gerade im Business Enterprise
Umfeld, dass viele Software, was man
tagtäglich benutzt, im Backend wahrscheinlich Java ist.
Aber nachdem ich mich
selbst ein bisschen mit Spring Boot
und Quarkus und neuem Java
beschäftigt hab, muss ich sagen,
es gibt erstaunlich viel gutes
Zeug für Java
und JVM.
Aber wir können mal gucken,
gibt es
Flash-AP? Okay, also
das ursprüngliche Flash-AP
ist anscheinend eine
Python-Geschichte, oder?
Oder was
schreibt der
Dude hier?
Was ist denn das Python Projekt?
Api Flash?
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Flask kenne ich, ja.
Ja, okay, keine Ahnung.
Also ich weiß nicht, auf welche Python-Version er anspielt.
Aber anscheinend gibt es...
Aber gibt es denn .NET Create API from EF Core Model?
Framework.
Aber ja, sowas habe ich tatsächlich noch nie gesehen für .NET.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Naja, GraphQL würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt dazu zählen.
greft ist das ja komplett eigenes ding das hat er mit mit create update lied nichts zu tun das
ist ja quasi mehr oder weniger so eine eigene query language an sich für sich ja gut aber
kannst du machen ja es gibt auch komplette fertige greft l endpunkte für postgres zum beispiel aber
das würde ich genau das würde ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt zu sehen dass das das gleiche
ist.
Da geht es ja, glaube ich,
eher darum, wenn es schnell gehen muss.
Ja, normalerweise sagt man ja,
die Datenbankmodels
und diese
Transferübertragungsmodels
sollen unterschiedliche sein.
So quasi DTO
und P... Ach, keine Ahnung,
wie das Zeug heißt. Leute, ich bin kein Hauptberuflicher
Softwareentwickler, ich muss das nicht wissen.
Aber ich finde das jetzt erstmal, wenn es schnell gehen muss, dann finde ich, klingt das hier erstmal nach einer sinnigen Idee.
Was sagen denn die Leute auf Reddit zu?
Wobei Reddit, Reddit ist auch so ein bisschen ein Ding, ne?
Also Reddit, Twitter, das Heise-Forum, das Mikrocontroller-Forum, da hast du schon Spezialleute, je nachdem wo du unterwegs bist.
Auf Reddit ist immer so ein bisschen, je nachdem wo du guckst.
Wenn ihr euch auf Reddit mal komplett unterschiedliche politische Ansichten zum gleichen Thema geben wollt,
müsst ihr einmal das gleiche Thema in slash.de lesen und einmal das gleiche Thema in slash.berlinpublic.
Das könnte nicht unterschiedlich sein, Alter.
Aber beide Seiten, egal wo ihr guckt, drehen komplett am Rad immer.
Okay, die Java-Leute finden das schon mal toll.
Gut, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
GPUI Component
RAS GUI Components for Building
Fantastic Cross-Platform Desktop Applications
Da bin ich mal gespannt
Was ist EPUI?
Hab ich noch nie gehört
GUI
A Fast Productive UI Framework for RAS
Ach, das sind die für Z
Wisst ihr, was bei einem GUI-Framework echt sinnvoll wäre auf der Starterseite?
Screenshots!
Warum gibt es keine Screenshots auf der Startseite?
Hello World-Example, Animation-Example, Menüs.
Okay, es gibt...
Gibt es hier keine Screenshots oder was?
Das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein.
WTF?
Ist das denn ihr Ernst?
Ein GUI-Framework ohne Screenshots?
Ja.
But why?
Warum?
Warum macht man ein GUI-Framework und eine Seite dafür
und hat nicht mal Screenshots, wie das aussieht?
Das kann das geilste GUI-Framework sein.
aber ich hätte jetzt schon keinen bock mehr mir das weiter anzugucken geht
einfach svg ordner ok wir gucken wir gucken
moment examples svg
nicht wirklich okay es gibt es gibt keine das finde ich schon mal
fragwürdig. Haben die hier denn wenigstens
haben die hier denn wenigstens
Screenshots?
Alter, what?
Okay, ich
gette, dass man demonstrieren
möchte, was das GUI-Framework
alles Geiles kann.
Aber das ist vielleicht
etwas overloaded als
Exempel.
Und sieht jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich hübsch aus.
Übrigens, das ist ein weiterer Nachteil, den ich gerade sehe, wenn man nur in Containern
entwickelt.
GUI-Anwendungen kann man vergessen.
Es gibt halt wieder auch keine Screenshots, gescheit.
examples vielleicht bei den examples hello world die mögen das nicht hier
okay hier gibt es hier gibt es das sieht ein bisschen das sieht ein bisschen aus
wie ein browser halt
es sieht aus wie im browser nur dass es anscheinend nicht im browser ist es sieht
Es sieht aus wie CSS.
Wie die alten Bootstrap-Button.
Es sieht aus wie im Browser.
Das ist aber anscheinend nicht im Browser.
Sondern das ist was?
Oder ist es doch im...
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Rust und Wasm ist es.
ein gui framework ist glaube ich so ziemlich eines der aufwendigsten dinger
die man machen kann gerade ein cross-platform gui framework
microsoft hätte eigentlich die chance für dort netz ein gutes cross-platform framework
rauszubringen aber microsoft ist halt unfähig was das angeht was die frameworks angeht und
Cross-Plattform schon mal gar nicht.
Für .NET gibt es da nur
Avalonia ernst zu nehmen und Avalonia
hat halt auch immer noch ekliges XML für
GUI. Also ich weiß nicht.
So sehr ich C-Sharp und .NET
mag als Plattform für GUI-Sachen
ist nix. Es gibt generell eh
kaum was für gescheite
Cross-Plattform-Desktop-GUIs.
Es gibt nicht wirklich viel.
GTK ist Cross-Plattform
voll für'n Arsch.
Breaked bei jedem meiner Update.
du hast Qt, wo du nicht genau weißt,
wie du es gescheit verwenden sollst,
wenn nicht gerade eine C++-Anwendung ist.
Du hast Avalonia,
du musst dich mit XML rumschlagen.
Uno habe ich
nur ganz kurz mal ausprobiert, keine Ahnung.
Es gibt einfach nichts
gescheites Desktop-mäßiges Cross-Plattform.
Da muss man sich nicht wundern, dass alle nur noch
Elektron-Anwendungen machen.
Maui ist der größte Shit ever.
Außerdem ist es auch eklig, das XML.
Da musst du dich nicht wundern, dass die Leute eigentlich nur noch...
...ihre Webanwendung in den Browser packen und das als Binary ausliefern.
So, mit einem gebandelten Node.js dabei.
Nur noch Elektronen gedünst.
Weil der Kram sieht halt wenigstens auf jeder Plattform dann gleich aus.
Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Die Webview, ich finde Webview ist halt auch übelster Crap.
Aber auf der anderen Seite wahrscheinlich immer noch das Beste, wenn du dich nicht selbst unglücklich machen willst.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich finde an Discord sieht man, dass das durchaus funktioniert.
Discord ist jetzt allerdings sicherlich keine High-Performance-Anwendung, wie sie sich anfühlt.
Allerdings hat Discord selbst natürlich auch einige Funktionen, wo Performance wichtig ist.
Desktop, Screensharing und solche Geschichten.
Und ich habe mal über Discord einen Artikel gelesen, dass Discord wohl, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch so ist, ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass Discord wohl, wenn man die Native Desktop-Anwendung verwendet, einige selbstentwickelte Node.js-Module hat in C++,
damit Discord auf dem Desktop schneller ist. Flutter ist wohl ganz nice für Mobile-Anwendungen,
allerdings ist Flutter wohl weniger nice für Cross-Platform-Desktop-Anwendungen.
Wir haben sogar mal eine Linux-Desktop-Anwendung gebaut in Flutter. Irgendwann vor drei Jahren
oder vier Jahren im Stream. Wann probierst du mal eine neue Programmiersprache aus?
habe ich aber erst letztes Wochenende.
Naja, so neu.
Ist halt die Frage, welche.
Und ob sich das lohnt.
So random irgendwelche
Programmiersprachen ausprobieren,
weil da einer auf Reddit drüber gepostet hat,
die null Traction hat,
keine Libraries,
unfertig ist,
sich bei jedem Release ändert.
Weiß ich nicht, ob ich da großartig Bock drauf habe.
Also auf D habe ich garantiert keinen Bock drauf.
Das weiß ich jetzt schon.
ich will halt immer noch, wenn ich sowas lerne,
will ich halt immer noch einen gewissen
Sinn dahinter sehen, ja.
Wenn ich mir Rust
angucke, sag ich, okay, das kann man bestimmt
mal irgendwann gebrauchen, außerdem hat es ziemlich Hype,
ist verbreitet, hat
ein großes Ökosystem, okay, verstehe ich.
Wenn ich mir Python-Zeug angucke, sag ich, ja gut, kann man auch gebrauchen.
JavaScript auch.
Ruby würde ich mir jetzt heutzutage auch nicht mal
angucken, auch wenn ich Ruby mag, aber
Ruby ist halt dadurch, dass Ruby on Rails
so gut wie verschwunden ist.
Auch nicht mal angesagt.
Java, C Sharp
geht mittlerweile auch ohne Probleme.
Ich kann ja sogar halbwegs brauchbar
C++ programmieren, auch wenn das die
beschissenste Sprache aller Zeiten ist, Leute.
Ich hab letztens was auf Reddit,
nicht auf Reddit, auf Twitter gepostet.
Ey.
Seriously, Leute.
Das ist ein Beispiel.
Nee, ich hab mir kein Beispiel rausgesucht,
was besonders
beschissen ist. Das ist ein Beispiel
aus der offiziellen
Beschreibung,
aus der offiziellen Feature-Beschreibung
des C++
Standards.
Also das ist ein Beispiel,
was
dieses Feature verdeutlichen soll
und möglichst gut lesbar
sein soll. Also ich hab,
wenn du dir hässliches C++
raussuchen willst, geht das noch viel schlimmer.
Aber das ist ein Beispiel, das ist ein gutes C++ Beispiel, was gut und schön sein soll von den offiziellen C++-Machern.
Mittlerweile ist es halt so, du hast bald eine random Anordnung von Sonderzeichen in C++ und das ist gültig.
Was das macht, ich glaube, ich kann dir sagen, was das macht.
das sorgt dafür dass du einen namen zu string machen kannst
also wenn du den namen hast ja du hast jetzt in ams zum beispiel hier weg
w omega 0 das sind deine namens hier ja okay immer in am emote so das ist ein
Was ja, übrigens, by the way, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr das wisst, aber in C++ konntest du bisher nicht sagen, Emote, also du konntest bisher nicht sagen, ich mach jetzt einfach mal so, es ist jetzt kein gültiges C++, ja, okay, aber was du bisher nicht sagen konntest, ist sowas hier.
Das geht nicht
Das ist nicht möglich
In C++
Das geht nicht
Du kannst Enums nicht
In lesbare
Sachen printen
In C++
Das geht nicht
Dafür gibt es dann so hässliche Libraries
Weil die Leute halt festgestellt haben
In-Nam-to-String ist gar nicht so dumm.
Also, in jeder normalen Programmiersprache
würdest du jetzt vielleicht sowas hier machen.
Okay?
Ja?
Oder meinetwegen Go.
In Go würde das Ganze dann irgendwie sowas heißen.
Ja?
Das wäre jetzt hier irgendwie der Go-Way.
Aber nicht in C++.
In C++ geht das nicht.
Deswegen gibt es dann solche Libraries wie Magic Enum.
Mit denen du Enums zu Strings umwandeln kannst und sowas.
Und wo wir gerade bei hässlichem C++ sind.
So, da brauchst du halt solche Dinger,
weil sich da keiner bisher überlegt hat,
dass ein Inham to String eine gute Idee wäre, okay?
So, und ich glaube, was diese Funktion macht, ist,
das benutzt
das neue Reflection Feature
von C++.
Das erkennt man daran, dass es dieses Hütchen
E ist. By the way, es gibt auch
die Möglichkeit Hütchen Hütchen E zu
machen in C++. Fragt mich aber bitte nicht, was
das bedeutet. Ich glaube, diese
Funktion benutzt das neue
C++ Reflection Feature
um
Enums in
lesbare Strings umzuwandeln.
Warum es dafür sowas braucht
Warum es dafür kein normales Konstrukt
In der Sprache gibt
Keine Ahnung
Weil es C++ ist
Und das C++ Gremium
Denkt sich halt
Warum einfache Sachen machen
Wenn man auch komplizierte Scheißsachen machen kann
Und so kommen all diese Sachen zusammen
Was es macht genau
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung
Also das hier verstehe ich noch
Okay
das ist wie wenn du in C Sharp
sagst
Generic I oder sowas
das ist Generic
so
Requires Standard ist Inam
das ist glaube ich ein Compile Time Check
dass der Typ auf den
das Template angewendet werden
kann ein Inam sein muss
ConstExpo ist
auch ein Compile Time Check
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment
Warum kann Enum to String
Constexpr sein?
Ah, weil das zur Compile Time
passiert
Also zur Compile Time werden hier Enums
in Strings umgewandelt
Dann gibt es
Standard String Result Unnamed
Das ist halt das Default Wert
für den Enum
Dann gibt es irgendwie eine super
krasse Magic Geschichte
Kräfte, warum fragst du mich auf Englisch?
Du kannst doch Deutsch.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Aber nein, hatte ich noch nicht.
Mal gucken, ob ich das mache.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, dann mach.
Ne, hatte ich noch nicht.
Hatte ich noch nicht.
Ob ich das mache, bin ich mir auch gar nicht mehr so sicher.
Mal schauen.
So, was das hier macht,
hat absolut keinen
Plassen Schimmer.
Doppel, also
Eckige Klammern, Doppelpunkt, Expand
Ich wusste bis dahin nicht mal, dass das gültige Syntax ist
Standard Meta-Enumerators
Das hier ist diese Reflection-Syntax
E, Doppelpunkt
Ey, absolut keine Ahnung
Warum es jetzt hier auf einmal zwei Pfeile braucht, keine Ahnung
Das hier ist eine Lambda, vermutlich eine Reference-Capture
Auto-E, was ist überhaupt E in dem Fall?
E ist vorher noch überhaupt nicht belegt.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
If value.
Wo kommt denn value überhaupt her?
Value ist doch hier nirgendswo angelegt bisher.
Ach doch, hier. Value.
Aber E ist nirgendswo angelegt.
Ach, E. Moment. E kriegt man dann übergeben
von innen.
Also wenn value gleich
Topfelpunkt E.
Keine Ahnung.
Name of Enum.
Also in den String wird dann der Name vom Enum reingeschrieben.
Keine Ahnung.
Es ist nicht lesbar und es ist auch nicht wirklich zu verstehen, was hier passiert.
Wollen wir mal Chat-GPT fragen?
Chat-GPT kann auch mittlerweile Screenshots, oder?
Was macht das?
Bam.
Analyzing Image
Das ist C++ Code, der zur Compile-Zeit eine Funktion erzeugt
Mit der man einen Inam-Wert in seinen Namen als String umwandeln kann
Ich finde es übrigens mega krass
Dass überhaupt sowas notwendig ist in C++
Warum gibt es nicht einen Inam
ein I-Namen
oder warum gibt es nicht wenigstens
ein C++ Teil?
Standard I-Namen
convert
to string.
Das wäre die C++ Variante.
Warum gibt es nicht wenigstens sowas?
Okay.
Zum Beispiel
I-Namen-Klasse
So ungefähr
Soll dann ungefähr
Green zurückgeben, das finde ich auch geil
Das Chat
Das soll dann ungefähr
Green zurückgeben, das weiß selber nicht so
Genau, was C++ an der Stelle da so
Treibt, ja
Was passiert im Code?
Der entscheidende Teil ist
Funktion funktioniert, das wissen wir, das wissen wir
Ja, so weit habe ich das auch.
So weit habe ich es auch vorhin erklärt.
Das habe ich auch noch erklärt.
Jetzt, der interessante Teil ist...
Ah, Moment. Okay, sorry, ChatGPT.
Das da oben ist der entscheidende Teil
und das hier ist der interessante Teil.
Also der interessante Teil ist nicht unbedingt
der entscheidende Teil, ja?
Classic C++.
Der interessante Teil ist...
Okay.
Okay, das verwendet C++ Reflection Metaprogramming aus den neuen C++ Reflection Entwürfen, um über alle Inam-Werte von E zu iterieren.
Das hätte ich beim besten Willen hier nicht drin herauslesen können, dass das quasi eine Schleife ist.
Das ist eine Schleife.
Und normalerweise machst du doch
normalerweise machst du doch Compile-Time-Schleifen
irgendwie so in C++
Für jeden Enumerator wird geprüft
if value
also ist der übergebene Wert gleich
diesem Inham-Wert, wenn ja, gibt es seinen Namen
zurück
Aha, vereinfacht
Der Code macht konzeptionell also
eine Vorschleife
Man muss nicht selbst eine Switch-Anweisung schreiben.
Ohne Reflection müsste man das so machen.
Ja gut, ohne Reflection, es wäre auch sinnvoll, wenn es einfach ein Sprachkonstrukt gäbe,
was defaultmäßig in der Sprache drin ist oder Standard-Library was,
was Enums to Strings, weil wer will denn bitteschön schon Enums to Strings umwandeln?
Kommt ja nie vor.
Generell muss man sagen, C++, Standard Library und Strings ist der komplette lächerliche Witz.
Ich meine, Chad, wer will schon String Handling machen in seinem Programm?
Strings werden so selten verwendet, das kann man eigentlich sein lassen.
Wer braucht schon String Handling?
Strings sind bloated.
Alles durch Konstants ersetzen.
Also, das, also
ChatGPT erklärt das gut, aber es ist halt
einfach immer noch richtig hardcore
Dumm, richtig dumm
So, und den Code, den ich her habe
Den Code
hab ich hier her
Also, ich hab das, das ist offizieller
C++ Code vom Gremium
Es wird ja immer schlimmer
What the fuck
Was
Also
Ich dachte eigentlich
Alter wer zum Teufel soll das lesen
Ich
Ich bilde mir ein
Ich hab das von...
Ich hab das von Open Standard
hab ich das kopiert.
Dieses Beispiel.
Oder anscheinend doch nicht.
Relativ, relativ...
Wie oft gibt's da eigentlich die Kla...
Hier ist es doch!
Das Beispiel hab ich einfach nur kopiert aus dem Standard.
Ich habe gesucht...
Keine Ahnung.
Examples oder...
Ich habe irgendwas nach C++ Reflection gesucht.
Und dann bin ich hier auf Open Standard gekommen.
Also das ist quasi die offizielle Beschreibung dieses Features.
Das heißt, was man hier sieht, ist die bestmögliche...
Das beste Beispiel, was man machen kann für dieses Feature.
Und es sieht immer noch hässlich wie die Nacht aus.
Das ist so der Witz.
Es geht natürlich noch hässlicher, ne?
Das ist klar.
Wenn man sich das hier anguckt...
Wenn man sich das hier anguckt, dann ist natürlich noch...
Ach, das ist die...
Ach, das ist, wo es überhaupt erst alles implementiert ist.
Ja, ja, ja.
Na gut, genug C++-Rage.
Zack, zack, zack.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier für interessante Software?
ML, Machine Learning Powered
Manga Translator. Leute,
Ayaya-Time.
Das war was für euch, oder?
Ups. Ah, ich hab,
ich verdrück mich die ganze Zeit gerade.
Das ist doch was für die Weeps unter uns.
Welche Models benutzt das?
Paddle, Manga OCR, Baberu.
Aha, nie gehört.
Fresh.
Terminal-based IDE und Texteditor.
Easy, powerful and fast.
Ja, die Rust-Leute haben einen Trend, haben einen Hang dazu, die Sachen neu zu implementieren, die es eigentlich schon gibt.
Hier hat wieder mit FFmpeg einer ein super hässliches GIF gemacht.
Leute, ich sag's euch, man kann mit FFmpeg auch schöne GIFs machen, ne?
Wollte ich nur mal erwähnen, das geht. Also man kann mit FFmpeg schöne GIFs machen.
Diese Pixel-GIFs ist der Default, aber das geht mit FFmpeg auch viel schöner.
Ja, hier ist schon viel schöneres GIF.
So, und warum soll ich Fresh verwenden?
Die richtig coolen Leute benutzen doch eh einen krass customizierten Neo-Wim, oder?
Oder es gibt mittlerweile so Kack-Noobs wie ich, die einfach die Jetbrains-IDEs verwenden.
Fresh.
Testimonials.
Es ist der beste Editor aller Zeiten.
Orchestration Tool.
Aha.
Das heißt, es ist eigentlich eher für KI-Gedöns gedacht, oder was?
Wüsste ich jetzt nicht, wozu und warum und weshalb.
Warum habe ich das hier offen?
Man weiß es nicht.
So, eine Sprache.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Chat.
Jemand Vorschlag?
Vielleicht mal was,
wo es auch wirklich interessante Projekte gibt.
Habt ihr eine Idee?
Ein Trending.
Nein, nein, nein.
Nicht C++.
Sick.
Das machen wir. Das haben wir lange nicht mehr reingeguckt.
C++ rage ich doch eh nur wieder rum.
Go haben wir die letzten Wochen schon immer geguckt.
Malen wir irgendwie was anderes.
Wie spricht man das aus?
Scheme? Scheme?
Ist das nicht irgendein so ein Lisp-Ding?
Mit ganz vielen Klammern?
Pern haben wir letzte Woche geguckt.
Ja, das sind doch ganz viele, ganz viele Klammern.
Sieht aus wie IMAX Lisp.
MLX Surf.
Okay, das ist für Apple.
KI-Stells.
shelly lpm packmann alternative für archivungs habe ich schon mal installiert fand ich ganz
nice vorteil gegenüber jay und packmann nie so wirklich gesehen aber finde ich
weiß dass es gibt ghosty feature rich and cross platform terminal emulator das user
platform-exceleration.
Ich frage mich,
was hat Ghosty,
was Westerm
nicht hat und umgedreht und
ist Ghosty irgendwas,
was man sich
mal angucken sollte?
Also quasi,
Ghosty vs. Westerm.
Why the hype?
Westerm is so much more.
Aha.
FFFM-Pack, die hatten lange Zeit Probleme mit diesen WebM, WebP-Formaten.
Ja und? Aber das ist doch gar kein GIF, das ist WebP.
Achso, man kann es direkt zu GIFs umwandeln.
Okay.
Also, vielleicht haben sie das verbessert.
Vielleicht haben sie das verbessert.
Früher sahen die Default GIFs, die FFM Pack erzeugt hat, echt mies aus.
Da musste man Trick 17 machen mit Farbpaletten.
Dass es gut aussah.
Development of Western
has practically ceased, das stimmt doch
überhaupt nicht, was die Leute auf Reddit immer
für einen Scheiß erzählen
Guck mal
Pass mal auf
Development has ceased, ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie das
aussieht, wenn Development has ceased hat, laut Reddit
Also vor 20 Stunden letztes Commit
Und 15. August Commits
12. August, 10. August
5. August, 4. August
Also hier
eindeutig, eindeutig, es ist komplett
komplett cease, das Development.
Also quasi 80
Comets oder 40 Comets
allein schon im August.
Komplett cease Development.
Vor 10 Monaten war das genauso.
Vor 10 Monaten habe ich den Kram ja sogar noch
mit Daily Bills draufgesucht.
Das ist das Problem, was ich vorhin angesprochen habe.
Ich weiß, warum der das denkt.
Weil die keinen Stable Release rausgehauen haben.
Das ist das, was ich vorhin gesagt habe.
Das ist ein bisschen blöd.
Die müssen unbedingt mal einen neuen Stable Release raushauen.
Da wird total viel Zeug dran entwickelt.
Aber die hauen keinen Stable Release raus.
Das letzte Stable Release ist von 2024.
Okay, also warum jetzt mal, warum sollte ich Ghostie verwenden?
Okay, na gut
Ich mein, wenn der das in Westerm
Subreddit schreibt, ob die Leute
Westerm oder Ghosty besser finden
Naja
Ja, also ich sehe jetzt auch keinen Vorteil, warum ich unbedingt Ghostie verwenden sollte.
Was ist mit dem los?
Moment, Moment mal, guck mal.
30 MB vs. 101 MB.
Er hat nicht genug Platz.
Also, seine Terminal-Auswahl hängt davon ab,
ob er 70 MB mehr oder weniger braucht.
In 2026.
Okay, das war 2025.
Fuck.
Okay, warum sollte ich Ghosty verwenden?
Was kann denn Ghosty Tolles?
Chat, vielleicht könnt ihr mir Ghosty schmackhaft machen.
Ghosty, also.
Es hat eine tolle
Gastri-Animation.
Hat eine schnelle Webseite, finde ich schon mal gut.
Features.
Okay, Ghosty.
Feature-Rich-Terminal.
Es ging nicht um RAM.
Es ging um
Executable-Size.
Windows-Tabs-and-Splits
hat es Zooms. Das ist schon mal ganz
wichtig.
Ligajas.
Verwende ich eh nicht.
Raphine Clustering. Kitty Graphics
Protocol.
Okay, pass mal auf.
Ghosty.
So.
So, es sieht schon mal out of the box ganz brauchbar aus
Was man jetzt über West
Haben nicht unbedingt sagen konnte
So, wie
Wie mach ich denn
Wie mach ich denn hier Splits
Okay, Tabs mach ich so
Die Tabbar gefällt mir nicht
Ich hoffe die kann man anders konfigurieren
Wie mach ich Splits
Die Fallkeybindings
bindings overview lässt key bindings default ok
split news blitz control shift e ok
Control-Shift-E
Split-Zoom
Control-Shift-Enter
Okay, das ist gut
Das kann schon mal
Die wichtigsten Sachen hat es schon mal
New Split
Wie split ich vertikal?
Seht ihr, wie man vertikal splittet?
command palette okay use control o command palette
split
Horizontal.
Split.
Okay.
Paste vom Clipboard.
Okay, das macht auf den ersten Blick tatsächlich einen ganz brauchbaren Eindruck.
Oh, man hat sogar ein Rechtsglückmenü.
mittlere Maustaste Paste geht nicht.
Das ist schon mal komisch.
Aber das kann man bestimmt einstellen.
Paste geht nur über Tastatur aktuell.
Macht doch einen ganz brauchbaren Eindruck.
Ich hoffe nur, man kann das
man kann diese
Leiste hier oben irgendwie umschalten.
Weil ich finde das hier einfach viel nicer.
Ich lasse es mal installiert.
Vielleicht ist Ghosty was,
was man sich mal angucken kann.
Aber ich wüsste halt nicht, also ganz ehrlich, ich kann...
Ah, wichtigste. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wichtigste Sache ist,
hat es
Image Support,
Leute.
Das müssen wir checken.
Also ohne GIF-Image-Support im Terminal kann ich ja nicht
geht ja nicht konflikt open config
keine ahnung
Also das kann er schon mal nicht
So, wie macht man
Image
Wie, okay, ghosty
How do I show image
a ghost selbst kann das nicht
man braucht extra image viewer okay
es kann das nicht direkt selbst man braucht ein image im image viewer dafür ja okay
Was haben die da eben installiert für ein Imageview?
View? Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Simple Terminal Imageview.
Was es nicht alles gibt, Alter.
Okay. View.
View. View.
So. Downloads.
Okay.
Schon mal ganz gut.
Animierte GIFs im Terminal
funktionieren.
So muss das schon mal sein.
Resize funktioniert nicht richtig, aber egal.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt mal ausprobieren?
Wie sieht das in X-Term aus?
Aber immerhin.
Ich meine, X-Term kann keine Bilder.
Immerhin, man erkennt es.
Man erkennt es.
Ich meine, immerhin kann dieses Programm...
So viel Traffic ist das.
Immerhin kann das...
das halbwegs rendern auch in x-terme ich muss ehrlich sagen ich finde das sieht
fast noch besser aus als die anderen
erst mal wieder an installen brauchen wir nicht
aber ghosty macht auf den ersten blick einen guten eindruck
rio term hat mir nicht so gut gefallen war ganz so war in ordnung hat aber das
Zoom-Feature gemisst.
Okay. Rock.
Fast and friendly functional
language. So stimmt wieder
1000 Klammern.
Okay, Programmiersprachen,
die nicht direkt ein Hello World-Example haben.
Der fasst ein bisschen aus wie Rust.
Nur, dass es
String Interpolation gedönst kann,
was Rust ja glaube ich nicht kann.
Naja.
Tö ist was anderes.
OxWM.
Was soll das sein?
Ox.
DWM, but better.
Dynamic
Window Manager written in SIG.
Ist das auf Wayland-Basis
oder auf X?
Ah ja.
an ok es ist also auf x basis es ist nicht es ist nicht das ist nicht weil
and native
wenn ich das richtig sehe
money zeug das haben wir schon mal angeguckt in
headless browser den anbieter nicht als gesteuerten browser erkennen können
sollen nicht erkennen können lipp fax ist in deutschland schicken wir
noch gerne faxen letztens gehört dass bei uns benachrichtigungen über zugbrände
per fax verschickt werden keine ahnung ob das alles so stimmt aber ich habe
Ich hab nen Artikel gelesen, die Bahn hatte einen ICE-Brand oder sowas als Notfalltest.
Es war kein echter Brand, es war so ein, so ein, wie nennt man das, so ein Test, ob das alles funktioniert.
Und die waren super langsam, unter anderem, weil die sich die Meldung, dass es brennt, noch per Fax geschickt haben.
Ja, so ein Exempel wäre natürlich auch ganz sinnvoll.
Wir schauen mal die üblichen Sachen.
Es gibt... Moment.
What the fuck?
Was ist das?
Das ist eine Terminal-UI-Library,
die null Beispiele hat.
Documentation.
Okay, das kann man nicht wirklich dann benutzen, oder?
Gibt es da Examples vielleicht drin?
Ich gebe ja sowas immer ganz gerne eine Chance.
Examples.
Okay, ListView.
Haben wir Progress? Progress haben sie nicht.
Wichtig sind Table und Progress.
Also Terminal Libraries, Terminal UI Libraries,
die keine Progress...
Sag mal, Chat, seit wann kann man eigentlich in GitHub
nicht mehr das Projekt durchsuchen, in dem man ist?
Oder bin ich nur zu dumm?
Das geht nicht mehr, oder?
Das geht nur noch, weil man eingeloggt ist.
Oh Gott, geht ab, ey.
Warum facken die einen immer so ab?
Muss ich euch ja ehrlich sagen.
Ich finde nicht, dass SIG eine schöne Sprache ist.
anderer suchknopf links ja man da kannst du files suchen
aber du kannst nicht nach inhalten
also ich finde nicht dass sie eine schöne sprache ist wir haben ja in 12 streams war
bisschen sick gebastelt. Ich fand das echt sehr sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig. Auch diese
komische Pointer Syntax oder wie das ausgesehen hat.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
GitHub-Stats.
Better?
GitHub-Statistics.
Images. Okay, wie sieht sowas aus?
Ah.
Okay, das ist ganz cool,
wenn man ein fancy Image
in seinem Profile haben will.
Im Projekt haben will.
Oder im Profile haben will.
Okay.
Gut, Chat, da sind wir wieder auf aktuellem Stand.
Mal gucken, ob es in der Zwischenzeit schon wieder Updates gibt.
Weil Arch, by the way,
Pleading Edge.
Natürlich!
Moment.
Ich hab doch Ghosty gerade erst installiert.
heißt das jetzt zwischen dem,
dass ich Ghosty installiert habe
und jetzt,
in den letzten 5 Minuten, wurde Ghosty
schon wieder geupdatet?
Die wollen es aber wissen.
Die sind aber
extrem agile.
Sonntagvormittag.
Der ist bestimmt hier im Chat.
Ey, das wäre witzig zu wissen, wenn der hier im Chat ist,
weil dann könnte ich ein paar Sachen zu Ghostie fragen.
Stell Image Support, ja, ganz bestimmt.
Aber mich würde interessieren, sollte das wirklich der Fall sein,
was so der Main Selling Point quasi von Ghostie ist im Vergleich zu, nennen wir mal, Western.
weil es ist immer gut alternativen zu haben
ich fahre jetzt halt warum steigen sollte wenn die alternative quasi nur
einen abklatsch von dem alten ist so wenn das nicht etwas hat wo ich sagen
würde das ist der grund gefallen hat es mir bisher ja also es hat auf den ersten
blicken ganz guten eindruck gemacht ist das nicht der typ von hash ich korb der
Ghostie entwickelt? Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung.
Wollen wir nochmal gucken. Wer entwickelt
Ghostie?
Ghostie Ork.
Ghostie Ork. Ja, wissen wir nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Das habe ich noch nicht so weit verfolgt bisher.
Gut, dann sind wir wieder Bescheid.
Schauen wir mal.
Komm, wir können uns noch ein paar irgendwelche Videos angucken.
Synology vs. Ukraine.
Okay, das gucken wir uns nicht komplett an.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt, was er sagt.
Ich bin der Meinung, Ugreen schlägt Synology um Längen und Minisforum auch, wenn es um...
Also Minisforum schlägt auch Synology um Längen, wenn es rein um die Hardware geht.
Bei Synology bezahlt sie viel Geld für alte Hardware.
Plus so Fantasien wie Vendor-Login bei Festplatten, was sie dann wieder abgeblasen haben.
Was aber keiner wirklich mitbekommen hat, dass sie es wieder abgesagt haben.
Von der Software her macht Synology natürlich keiner was vor.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das Ugreen OS in irgendeiner Art und Weise an Synology rankommt.
Okay, auf geht's.
Ich denke, es macht Sinn, einen Schritt zurück zu gehen und mit der Drive-Lock-In zu beginnen, weil es...
Aber es ist wichtig, die Hardware auch zu bezeichnen.
Und das ist auch, wo Dinge geändert haben.
hast du ritter rewriting rittert in rust so dass man wahrscheinlich hast einfach nur den index
irgendwie drauf gemacht oder so die s 925 plus ist die latest for bay nas device that's knowledge
has and with those hard drive restrictions removed completely removed them from the equation it's
still genuinely one of the best if not the best pre-built nas device that you can buy but the
Die Harddrive-Restriktionen, oder ich würde sagen,
die Harddrive-Restriktionen sind das echte Problem.
Und mit dem in der Hand,
jetzt musst du anfangen, Hardware
versus Hardware zu vergleichen. Und sobald du das machst,
fängst du an, die Nase zu drücken.
Also, anders als Synology, wo sie
eine oder zwei, vier Nase-Devices haben,
Ugreen hat eine ganze Reihe, und du wirst
einfach alles finden, was du willst.
Also, die drei Geräte, die ich denke,
die meisten Menschen natürlich landen,
sind die DXP4800+, die DXP4800 Pro
und die DXP4800 GT.
Jetzt, obwohl sie alle sehr ähnlich sind,
sind sie auch sehr...
Oh shit!
Chat!
Ich habe immer noch vergessen,
mein Report einzureichen bei U-Cream
wegen dem Sponsoring.
Ich habe immer noch kein Geld.
Jetzt habe ich das schon gemacht
und habe noch nicht mal Geld dafür bekommen.
Pepo burn money.
Okay, juck mich nicht.
Der sagt im Prinzip das, was ich vorhin auch gesagt habe.
Es gibt keine Frist dafür.
Es gibt keine Frist.
Aber solange ich es nicht mache,
ist PepoBurnMoney angesagt.
Gut, ich gehackt. OMG.
Spannendes, was hier empfohlen wird.
Was ist dabei?
größter waldbrand hessens bei rodenbach
das ist gar nicht so weit weg von mir
lohnt sich glasfaser
oder kann ich mich bestimmt jetzt drüber aufregen aber das guckte digitale schlusslicht
ach der startiert mittlerweile schon wieder na wer hätte das gedacht dass wir mal irgendwas
in der richtung hinkriegen ist ja was sie auszudenken die videos die empfohlen werden
nicht so tolle
er bestimmt nicht mit einem mac mini ist das mac mini das ist gar kein mac mini
sieht nur so aus
traumjob lehrer okay wer denkt ernsthaft chat gibt es irgendjemand der von euch
ernsthaft denkt lehrer ist ein traumjob geht das ebaro vielleicht aber keine
Ahnung, ob er das immer noch so sieht jetzt, wo es soweit ist.
Feiership-Video. Ne, können wir auch mal gucken.
Lehrer ist, glaube ich, so ziemlich der schrecklichste
Beruf, den ich mir vorstellen könnte.
Feiership.
This new startup can query
anywhere you have been.
Okay, Moment.
Wir müssen mal ein bisschen
langsam machen.
Lass mal kurz gucken, was haben wir denn jetzt
Was ist das denn?
Nass Selbstbau Zwischenbericht
Okay, keine Ahnung, wo sieht man denn das
Nass? Alter!
Noch nicht
erkennen, aber dit wird
Was ist das?
Das sieht ja
wilder aus als bei mir
Aber bei mir ist es schon wild
Okay
Aber wenn es funktioniert, warum nicht?
Ich bin der Letzte, der irgendwas
zu ordentlichem Rechneraufbau sagt.
Bei mir muss das einfach funktionieren.
Aber Chat, ob er auch Mikrorisse im Mainboard hat,
wie ich bei meinem neuen Rechner?
Mein Nass.
Gestern sah, oder beim letzten Mal,
beim letzten Video,
Guck mal, der hat sich so Wechselrahmen selbst gebaut.
Alter, was hat der denn krasses vor?
Was hat der denn da übertriebenes vor, Alter?
Ich meine, da kriegst du ja von der Höhe her, was kriegst du denn da rein?
30 Festplatten oder so?
Das sah noch ein bisschen strukturierter aus.
Jetzt habe ich hier weitergebaut folgendermaßen.
Ich habe jetzt hier erstmal 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, ne 8, das ist eine Stütze.
8 Festplatten eingebaut.
Es kommen noch 4 rein.
Jetzt haben wir hier 1, 2, 3.
Nur 12 Festplatten?
Da hättest du auch ein x-beliebiges Storage-Gehäuse auch getan, oder?
Also 12 Festplatten.
So ein 19 Zoll Gehäuse.
Gut, das ist bestimmt nicht so günstig.
Wie das Setup hier.
Das Setup ist wahrscheinlich relativ günstig.
3x8TB, 6TB, 6TB, 4TB, 2TB und nochmal 8TB.
Man könnte auch einfach 2x24TB Platten nehmen.
Ja.
Dann RAID 1 und gut ist.
Und vielleicht noch eine für externes Backup.
Aber ey, das hat bestimmt seinen Sinn.
Ich werde ihm jetzt hier nicht erzählen, wie er sein NAS bauen soll.
Und die sind da jetzt erstmal reingesteckt.
Die sind auch verkabelt SATA-technisch.
Da habe ich hier ein Meter lange SATA-Kabel mir besorgt.
Server SATA-Kabel.
Und hier nochmal SATA-technisch angestellt.
Es gibt ein Meter SATA-Kabel.
Krass, wusste ich auch nicht.
Dann habe ich eingebaut.
Warte mal, ich muss das hier drauf scharf stellen.
eine das sieht ein bisschen aus das sieht ein bisschen aus wie so sass kabels m2 also
eine info aber ist es nicht ist es nicht sada adapter karte mit ist eine info ach hier ja ja
ja das ist das ist der nvm karte mit sata anschlüssen drauf um die karte oder eine
m2 karte da sind sechs sata ports drauf und dann habe ich ja hier ne real tech habe ich
nicht gemacht hat kein bock mich aufzuregen noch mal vier sata port so auf dem bord das
heißt ich habe jetzt hier zehn sata port zur verfügung ich muss jetzt aber erst mal
detail starten und gucken ob wirklich jeder einzelne sata port auch seinen eigenen sata
kanal ich glaube preis leistungsmäßig ist das wohl wirklich ziemlich nahe ist
wie reliable das ganze setup ist
keine ahnung ob der controller auf der nvm was taugt ihr
werdet ihr darüber dann wahrscheinlich was wird er denn darüber machen
zfz raid oder irgendwas mehrere dann ist das kein ding das ist so lange controller nicht
kompletter schrott es geht das schon bekommt wenn ich muss ich jetzt noch mal anders machen
vielleicht mit einer PCIe-Karte oder so.
Guck mal, hier ist diese passiv
gekühlte Asus
10 Gig Karte drin, glaube ich.
Dann habe ich eingebaut
32 Gigabyte Rahmen hier
und 32 Gigabyte Rahmen da.
Massive.
Das sind nämlich zwei.
Und hier
habe ich in jedem jeweils
eine 10 Gigabit.
Das ist eine ziemlich alte von Asus.
Ich kann
hier jetzt, oder ich werde hier
einen Proxmox Cluster
draus machen.
Dieser Proxmox Cluster wird...
Die Rechner sehen auch ein bisschen älter aus schon.
...meinen ganzen Festplatten
Array hier.
Wisst ihr, was er
garantiert für ein Problem kriegen wird?
Kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen.
Wenn eine Festplatte kaputt ist,
rauszufinden,
welche es ist.
Bei solchen Setups ist das einzige, wie das richtig funktioniert, eigentlich einen Aufkleber vorne mit der Seriennummer und dann im Log schauen, welche Seriennummer kaputt ist und die rausziehen.
Also nächstes ist, wo ich auch mir unschlüssig wäre, ob die Dinger Hotswap unterstützen, wenn es SATA-Ports über NVMe und irgendein Billig-Controller ist. Kann sein, kann nicht sein.
als Rezept oder als Rezept oder irgendwie sowas zusammenbauen werde ich mir überlegen
vibrationstechnisch mache ich mir da erstmal überhaupt keine Sorgen das ist jetzt so
versteifte Teil dass es funktionieren wird ja die Stromversorgung weiß ich noch nicht wie viele
Netzteile ich brauche und ob ich hier vielleicht noch mal ein größeres kaufen muss für die Festplatten
weil die Festplatten werden separat versorgt.
Und diese Netzteile schalte ich dann ein über ein ganz normales KFZ-Relais.
Das ist ein Autorelais, ein 12-Volt-Relais.
Da gibt es ein 12-Volt-Ruf und dann schaltet das Relais entweder diese beiden...
Aber ein ordentliches Netzteil packt doch 12 Festplatten.
Oder?
Ich meine, vielleicht wenn die alle gleichzeitig andrehen,
Kann es Probleme geben.
Aber selbst dann.
Oder?
Ist das ein Problem?
Weiß gar nicht.
Oder diese drei oder nur ein dieser Netzteile
schaltet diese Drillee dann zu.
Der Computer schaltet das Drillee.
Das Drillee schaltet das Netzteil.
Bums. Läuft alles.
Bums. Mehr wollte ich jetzt ja nicht sagen.
Sieht jetzt noch ein bisschen wild aus.
Das wird nachher noch richtig cool. Kabel verlegt und
und dann sieht das alles auch
Da bin ich mal gespannt,
wie schick das dann aussieht.
Da müssen wir mal ein Auge drauf halten.
Ist auf jeden Fall ein wildes Bild hier.
Ja.
Nices Bild.
Oh je, da muss ich, da muss, das ist Ragebait für mich, solche Beiträge.
Da weiß ich jetzt schon, dass ich da wieder hart gebaitet werde, was zu sagen.
VPN, Schutz oder Scan vom hessischen Rundfunk?
Moment, das gucken wir uns zuerst an.
Also meine Meinung zu VPNs kennt ihr ja, habe ich ein Video dazu gemacht.
Das da ist schon ein bisschen älter, ist aber immer noch aktuell.
Also wen das interessiert, was ich zu VPNs denke, kann sich das Video angucken.
Mal gucken, was die dazu sagen. Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Im Internet surft man nicht unerkannt.
Man bekommt vom Internetanbieter eine IP-Adresse zugewiesen, die ist wie ein Nummernschild.
Diese IP-Adresse macht das Gerät, mit dem man surft, identifizierbar.
wie ein Nummernschild. Diese IP-Adresse macht das Gerät, mit dem man surft, identifizierbar und verrät den...
Das stimmt nicht wirklich, aber wir wollen jetzt mal nicht päpstlicher sein als der Papst.
...geografischen Standort des Routers.
Wenn man eine Website besucht oder wenn man online zockt, wird dem Eigentümer des Servers die IP-Adresse angegeben.
Und der könnte sie, wenn er will, auch blockieren.
Wer das verhindern will, so Georg Schnurer vom CT-Magazin, kann über ein Virtual Private Network...
Das Schnurrer, der hat früher immer Dings gemacht hier im hessischen Rundfunk, CT-Magazin, das habe ich geguckt, wo ich klein war.
Verschleiert quasi meine Zugangsdaten. Das heißt, der Anbieter der Webseite weiß nicht, wer ich bin.
Anhand von der IP weiß der das nicht. Je nachdem, was das für eine Webseite ist und was der sonst noch macht, kann der das sehr genau wissen, wer ich bin.
Lässt man einen VPN-Dienst, dann ist ein VPN-Server zwischengeschaltet. Die Webseitenbetreiber sehen nur noch die IP-Adresse des VPN-Anbieters. Der leitet die Daten dann über eine blickdicht geschützte Verbindung in VPN-Tunnel weiter, ohne dass Dritte das sehen können.
Die Musik ist echt nervig, oder?
Damit ist es nicht mehr so einfach Profile anzulegen. Profile werden vor allen Dingen für die Werbung angelegt. Das heißt, ich kriege dann Werbung, die...
Aber gegen irgendwelches Browser Fingerprinting Cookie gestellst oder gar wenn du dich einloggst auf der Seite, könnt ihr auch nichts machen.
Zielgerechtet, wie es so schön es ist. Also ich habe irgendwo...
Wie alt ist das Video? 16 Stunden. Top aktuell.
Kriege ich in der nächsten Zeit lauter Schnullerwerbung.
Ich habe einen Kinderwagen gekauft und ruckzuck kriege ich noch mehr Kinderwagenwerbung.
VPN ist natürlich auch noch gut dafür, wenn ich verschleiern will, wo ich herkomme,
weil ich zum Beispiel Streaming diente aus dem Ausland, etwa aus Amerika.
VPN ist auch wichtig zum Linux-Distribution runterladen.
Habe ich gehört.
... da nutzen möchte, die ich in Deutschland nicht kann.
Da gibt es das sogenannte Geofencing.
Und das funktioniert so.
VPN-Anbieter haben Serverstandorte in vielen Ländern.
Wer zum Beispiel amerikanisches Netflix schauen möchte, wählt einen VPN-Server in den USA.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, das ist auch eines der wenigen Einsatzzwecke, wofür ich VPN sinnvoll finde, wenn du Geoblocking umgehen willst.
Ja, falls es Leute gibt, die irgendwelche Sachen sich illegal runterladen wollen, vielleicht auch sinnvoll, okay.
Da muss man aber natürlich dem VPN-Anbieter vertrauen, dass er nichts aufzeichnet und sonst wie.
Ich hab sein Ewigkeiten.
Nichts mehr runtergeladen, was Musik oder Filme oder irgendwas angeht.
Wirklich ewig her.
20 Jahre oder sonst was.
15, 20 Jahre, dass ich mal irgendwas runtergeladen habe.
Ich komme komplett mit YouTube-Music und Streaming-Anbietern aus.
Und umgeht so das Geofencing.
Auf diese Art können zum Beispiel Russen die in Russland gesperrten Dienste wie Instagram oder Facebook dennoch nutzen.
VPN macht das Surfen in jedem Fall langsamer.
Die Geschwindigkeit der VPN-Server ist inzwischen aber so hoch, dass das Bild nicht mehr ruckelt, was früher oft der Fall war.
Naja, also kommt ein bisschen drauf an.
Also VPN macht sich wirklich, also es kann sogar Verbindungen geben, die gehen schneller über VPN, weil es bessere Routen läuft.
Es gibt so Gaming-VPN-Dienste für Leute, die gerne MMOs in Korea spielen und sowas.
Da ist sogar das Routing über VPN manchmal besser als direkt und deswegen benutzen das die Leute.
Also das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen, dass es langsamer ist.
Ja, klar, potenziell, natürlich muss das auch über extra Zwischenwege.
Ich würde aber sagen, dass es nicht wirklich so spürbar ist.
Ich weiß, die Telekom empfiehlt das selbst.
Auf Twitter.
Viele Unternehmen nutzen ein eigenes VPN, um sensible Daten mit Kollegen und Kunden im blickdichten Tunnel auszutauschen.
Hier sind sie auch vor dem Zugriff Dritter geschützt.
Wenn ich tatsächlich sicher mit meinen Geschäftspartnern kommunizieren will, etwa weil ich im Homeoffice sitze und jetzt trotzdem auf die Rechner der Firma zugreifen will, da ist VPN natürlich super.
Idealerweise ein VPN, das ich selber aufgebaut habe, das also in meiner kleinen Firma läuft.
Das ist ja eines der Gründe, warum die auf EU-Ebene natürlich jetzt auch schon wieder mit VPN-Verbot und sowas da in den Köpfen spielen.
... läuft und ich auch selbst Kontrolle darüber habe, was mit den Daten passiert.
Aber Achtung, vor Schadsoftware schützt das nicht.
Deshalb gilt die alte Regel, du sollst nicht blöd klicken, auch im VPN.
Wenn ich dort eine Schadsoftware anklicke, dann installiert die sich, wenn ich dumm genug bin, auf meinem Rechner trotzdem.
Oder wie Semper Video sagen würde früher, Schadwehr.
Deshalb ist es ganz wichtig, dass der Rechner ordentlich geschützt ist. Das geht beim Betriebssystem los. Also alle aktuellen Patches einspielen, egal ob das jetzt Microsofts Windows ist oder von Apple das Betriebssystem oder auch ein Linux. Auch da, es sollte immer gesichert sein. Darüber hinaus ganz wichtig, der Browser, mit dem ich unterwegs bin, da gibt es ja auch Updates und auch die sollte ich regelmäßig.
U-Block Origin. Ohne U-Block Origin prinzipiell schon mal nicht ins Internet gehen.
Ich einspiele, am besten automatisch. Und zum Schluss, wenn ich es ganz gut mache, dann habe ich eben auch noch einen Virenschutz.
Manche VPN-Anbieter verlangen eine Gebühr.
Alter, die Musik!
Ihr Ziel ist aber immer dasselbe.
Wie laut möchte man die Musik machen im Vergleich zum Reden?
Geld verdienen.
Deshalb sitzen viele dieser VPN-Anbieter auch irgendwo auf lustigen karibischen Inseln, wo es steuerparadiesisch zugeht.
und die sind dann natürlich erstens niemand verpflichtet
und zweitens bieten sie in der Regel auch sehr wenig Verbraucherschutz.
Deshalb habe ich so ein bisschen Zuckungen,
wenn ich kostenlose Dienste höre in dem Zusammenhang,
denn irgendwo muss das Geld ja herkommen.
Das heißt, es muss ein Geschäftsmodell geben.
Genau.
Das heißt, die legen vielleicht...
Und das Ding ist halt,
das muss man bei solchen VPN-Sachen auch immer wieder erwähnen,
die Anbieter können enorm viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
entscheidend ist ja, ob man das denen glaubt.
Und du kannst es halt nicht nachprüfen, du hast keine Chance.
Also du musst das denen glauben.
Und das ist natürlich eine persönliche Sache,
ob man den meisten VPN-Anbietern glaubt,
dass sie das alles machen, was sie sagen,
oder dass sie das nicht machen, was sie nicht machen wollen.
Keine Ahnung.
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Also ich traue den meisten nicht.
Ich dann doch Profile von mir an oder vermarkten meine Anfragen auf andere Art und Weise oder blenden mir Werbung ein.
Das CT-Magazin empfiehlt deshalb nur kostenpflichtige Dienste.
Was bei unserer Übersicht ganz gut funktioniert hat, war zum Beispiel Asaya VPN, iVPN.
Das habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Mulvert, Proton.
Das kenne ich aus dem Stream. Das haben mir Leute, also als wir mal über das Thema VPN geredet haben, hat der Chat, ihr habt mir das hier empfohlen, obwohl ich gar kein VPN brauche, ja. Habt ihr gesagt, Max, Max, das beste VPN-Anbieter, weil man wohl dort, ich habe das nicht ausprobiert, ich gebe das jetzt wieder aus dem Stream, weil man wohl dort besonders anonym bezahlen kann.
Also da geht dann wohl wirklich auch sowas wie Geld in Briefumschlag stecken und dahin schicken.
VPN, um nur so ein paar zu nennen, das sind alles Dienste, die grundsätzlich erstmal verbraucherfreundliche Zugänge haben, die monatlich natürlich was kosten, zwischen 5 und 10 Euro.
Aber wenn ich denn unbedingt ein VPN will und es mir nicht selber aufsetzen kann, dann sollte ich mir das leisten.
Denn so weiß nur ich, wo mein Router steht.
euch bis zum Server, zum VPN-Endpunkt.
Nicht von euch bis zum Zielserver.
Also wenn ihr jetzt auf irgendeinen Web-Server zugreift,
dann ist der Traffic nur von euch bis zum VPN-Anbieter verschlüsselt.
Sobald es da wieder rausgeht, nicht.
Wenn ihr das über HTTPS macht, ist es was anderes,
aber es ist nicht mehr VPN-mäßig verschlüsselt.
Also wenn ihr irgendwelche Plaintext-Protokolle übers Internet macht und verschlüsselte Sachen übers Internet, dann ist das nach dem Ausgang beim VPN-Anbieter genauso lesbar wie vorher auch.
Also falls jetzt irgendjemand da Panik vor dem Geheimdienst oder whatever, keine Ahnung, was ihr da so treibt habt, das schützt euch da nicht davor.
dass es nicht mitgelesen werden kann.
Das kann euch vielleicht ein bisschen davor schützen,
dass dann jemand rausfinden kann,
wer ihr seid.
Wobei die auch ganz andere Möglichkeiten dann haben.
Da würde ich mich nicht drauf verlassen.
Aber es ist nicht
irgendwie von Anfang bis Ende verschlüsselt,
nur durch VPN.
Naja, ob du danach nicht mehr sichtbar bist, ist halt die Frage, was du überträgst, ne?
Wenn du dich danach mit deinem Google Account einloggst, ist es egal, ob es verschlüsselt ist oder nicht.
Von dir bis zum Anbieter und ob der Anbieter deine IP sieht, die wissen trotzdem, wer du bist.
Und wenn du mit dem gleichen Browser einmal über VPN und einmal ohne VPN drauf zugreifst und du schön gefingerprintet wirst im Browser,
kann es durchaus auch sein, dass du dann nicht mehr anonym bist.
Also anonym im Internet ist deutlich schwieriger, als man so denkt.
Dann gucken wir mal, warum der Glasfaserausbau stagniert.
Wenn der Chef seine Mitarbeiter zum Meeting trifft, bei den IT-Beratern von BPI-SEC läuft das digital.
Beraterbude.
Die Leute sehen...
Leute, die sehen schon so
krass nach Berater aus.
Wenn ich die Leute schon sehe, kriege ich
Anfälle.
Wie sehr nach Berater der heiße
Luft von sich gibt, willst du aussehen.
Genau so.
Der einzige, der Plan hat, ist wahrscheinlich
der oben rechts. Die sehen...
Ohne Scheiß. Genau so
stelle ich mir irgendwelche heißluftredenden
Berater vor.
Nur wenige der 15 Kollegen sind vor Ort im Büro, also werden Daten geteilt, Systeme überwacht, alles online.
Glasfaser ist hier Standard.
Unsere Kunden, wie aber auch unsere Mitarbeiter sind deutschlandweit verteilt.
Von daher ist für die Zusammenarbeit, der Austausch von Daten, der Austausch von Informationen,
Abhalten von Videokonferenzen, Kommunikation mit Kunden und Mitarbeitern,
Eine schnelle Internetleitung ist absolut essentiell.
Daran hängt für viele Unternehmen der gesamte Arbeitsalltag. Glasfaser hat da Vorteile.
Während DSL-Anschlüsse meist bis zu 250 Megabit pro Sekunde erreichen, sind bei Glasfaser 1000 Megabit.
Ja, und vor allem den scheiß Upload haben.
Und Megabit und mehr.
Na gut, bei VDSL sind immer ganz so schlimm.
...möglich. Vor allem beim Hochladen von Daten zeigen sich die Unterschiede.
Glasfaser ist deutlich schneller und stabiler.
wichtig und gerade und gerade wenn du halt hier so eine agentur oder irgendwie
sowas hast mit mehreren mitarbeitern damit dann kommst halt mit 250 dauer und
50 ab überhaupt nicht aus
ich chat genau das ist mein gedanke immer wenn ich die ganzen nur nach 15
berater sehe ich finde das wirkt total unseriös wenn die leute so seriös
wirken wollen ja genau
Wobei es ja die Leute auch irgendwie nicht davon abhält, sich scammen zu lassen, wenn die Leute unseriös wirken.
Ich meine, hat irgendjemand mal gedacht, alter, Karl S., der ist so seriös, mit dem will ich unbedingt irgendwas machen.
Ich habe übrigens gelesen, Karl S. sitzt in Untersuchungshaft.
Zufällig gestern irgendwo gelesen.
Frage ich mich einfach, warum hat das so lange gedauert?
Warum sollte sich niemand dafür interessieren?
Also erstmal Daten werden gerne überall gesammelt.
Von allen Beteiligten.
Und das nächste ist, wo wir uns ja auch schon dahin dazu bewegen und was bestimmt auch schon passiert ist,
das automatisch ausgewertet wird, was du sagst und was du machst und was du verschickst.
Und jetzt überleg dir mal, du schreibst irgendwas, was ein automatischer Scanner als verdächtig einstuft.
Ich kann mich da noch an ein Beispiel erinnern, das ist Jahre her.
da hat einer über eine Überweisung, ich glaube sogar ein Schweizer, ich glaube es war sogar ein Schweizer,
der hat auf seine Überweisung geschrieben, Anflug auf irgendwas, so wo er ankommt am Flughafen.
Und das hat die Antiterrorleute getriggert, weil die gedacht haben, der plant ihnen einen Anschlag am Flughafen.
So, und in der heutigen Zeit geht es ja nochmal in eine ganz andere Richtung. Wenn du dir Sachen anguckst wie Chat-Kontrolle und in Zukunft, was sie ja auch planen, das Scannen kleinzeitig auf Geräten.
und weißt du, was dann passieren wird?
Das kann ich euch jetzt schon garantieren.
Das ist so sicher wie das Abend in der Kirche,
dass das passieren wird.
Scannen von, also automatisches Scannen
und Scannen auf dem Gerät.
Ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen, was passieren wird.
Die Oma ist mit den Enkeln am See
und macht Fotos von denen.
Irgendeine KI scannt das Handy der Oma
oder scannt den Upload zu Google Images
und sagt, oho, die Oma hat Kinderpornos auf dem Handy.
Und auf einmal landet die Oma in irgendeiner Liste von Leuten,
die Kinderpornos besitzen.
Das wird passieren.
Das könnt ihr mir nicht erzählen, dass das nicht passieren wird.
False Positives werden passieren.
1000 Prozent.
Das kann ich euch jetzt schon so sagen,
das ist so sicher wie das Arm in der Kirche,
dass das passiert wird.
Ja, dann wird gesagt, okay,
Okay, ist ja nicht schlimm, weil da guckt ja noch ein Mensch drüber. Ganz ehrlich, so wenig Bock, wie wahrscheinlich die Menschen haben werden, die sich diesen Content angucken, sind da Falls Positives auch vorprogrammiert. Und ratzfatz hat die Oma eine Hausdurchsuchung. Das wird passieren. Das kann ich euch garantieren. Das wird früher oder später passieren.
Und wenn wir jetzt ein bisschen suchen würden, ist das garantiert auch schon passiert. Vielleicht nicht in diesem Fall, aber auch von automatischen Überwachungsmaßnahmen. Dazu kommt, dass jeder irgendwelche privaten Dinger hat, die man nicht der Welt mitteilen möchte.
Ja, das können Krankheitsfälle sein, ja, Krankheitssachen sein. Es können irgendwelche sexuellen Praktiken sein, die vielleicht nicht so massenkompatibel sind. Ja, muss ja nicht klar was Illegales sein. Es gibt genug, wovon jeder von uns wahrscheinlich genug hat, wo man nicht will, dass es irgendjemand mitbekommt.
Also, diese Sache mit, man muss sich keine Gedanken machen, halte ich für komplett kontraproduktiv.
Produktiv.
Dazu kommt ja auch,
und ich habe mich ja dazu,
was Chat-Kontrolle angeht,
und so schon mal ausgelassen,
dazu kommt,
dass diese Dinger, sobald sie da sind,
und das ist eigentlich auch ein viel größeres Problem,
dass sobald solche Möglichkeiten
zur Überwachung da sind,
da werden die auch genutzt.
Und da werden die nicht nur für das genutzt,
wofür sie ursprünglich eingeführt wurden.
Ursprünglich wird gesagt, man macht das zum Schutz der Kinder.
Kann keiner was dagegen sagen.
Man kann höchstens dagegen sagen, guckt mal, wie viele Sachen schon im Namen Schutz der Kinder eingeführt wurden
und dann zweckentfremdet wurden, aber kann man eigentlich erstmal nichts dagegen sagen.
Der nächste Schritt ist, dass man sagt, man möchte das auch zur Verfolgung von Terroristen einsetzen.
Kann man auch nichts mehr dagegen sagen.
Danach kommt, man möchte das zur Verfolgung von schweren Straftaten wie Mord einsetzen.
Kann man auch nichts dagegen sagen.
Das wird dann immer weiter verwässert, bis dann irgendwann kommt,
Aber man könnte es ja auch zum Verfolgen von Urheberrechtsverstößen einsetzen. Man könnte es ja auch dagegen einsetzen gegen Hassrede im Internet. Wer gerade an der Macht ist, definiert dann, by the way, was Hassrede im Internet ist.
und sobald du das hast
ist vorbei
zumal in diesem Zuge natürlich dann auch so Sachen
eingeführt werden wie
oder diskutiert werden wie
Social Media Verbot für Jugendliche
oder für Kinder
schrägstrich Jugendliche
wo man dann auch wieder sagt, das macht man nur zum Schutz der Kinder
aber was in diesem Zuge auch eingeführt wird
ist eine Kontrollinfrastruktur
was Alterskontrolle
angeht
und dann hast du so Dinger wie, du kannst diesen Service nur noch benutzen,
wenn du dich mit der offiziellen App Altersverifiziert hast.
Das heißt, du hast dann quasi auch noch gleich einen Identitätsnachweis.
Du kannst dann Sachen nicht mehr anonym posten.
Und da wird es natürlich dann schon gefährlich,
wenn du nicht mehr anonym posten kannst im Internet, auf Social Media oder so,
wenn du dir Luft machen möchtest darüber, dass die aktuelle Regierung,
wer auch immer das jetzt sein mag, Scheiße baut,
vielleicht auch in ziemlich kräftigen Worten,
dann musst du damit rechnen, dass du demnächst eine Hausdurchsuchung hast.
Und das sind so Dinge, das sollten wir nicht so weit kommen lassen.
Deswegen finde ich den Ansatz, es kann einem ja egal sein, nicht gut,
weil es kann einem immer nur so lange egal sein, wie es einen nicht trifft.
Aber irgendwann trifft es dich.
Es geht in der EU Richtung China, ja, ist eindeutig.
Deswegen verstehe ich auch gar nicht, warum die alle immer so auf China oder Russland oder Weißrussland oder irgendwelche südamerikanischen Länder,
warum die immer so da drauf deuten und sagen, ah, guck mal, was für böse Sachen die da machen und Massenüberwachung und guck mal hier, die sind genau auf dem gleichen Weg.
Ich weiß nicht, warum unsere Massenüberwachung besser sein sollte als die Massenüberwachung in China.
Ja, natürlich, würden sie sagen.
Weil bei uns macht man das ja nur zum Besten der Leute.
Ja, fragt mal in China, warum die das machen.
Selbstverständlich sagen die auch,
das machen die dann nur zum Besten der Leute.
Aber bei uns ist das ganz was anderes.
Und wir sind so moralisch überlegen,
dass das bei uns viel besser ist.
Ja.
Also wie gesagt, ich finde,
das sollte man erst gar nicht mit anfangen.
Es passiert doch jetzt schon.
Politiker irgendwie auf Twitter mit einem dummen Meme,
bisschen durch den Kakao gezogen, Hausdurchsuchung.
Dass es da nicht riesen Dinger drumherum gibt, ist eh ein Unding.
Das muss sofort eigentlich, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, direkt zum Rücktritt von den Leuten führen,
aber das kann nicht sein.
Das kann nicht sein.
Es ist so, dass du als Politiker, aus meiner Meinung nach, musst du sogar noch mehr Kritik aushalten und auch bis zu einem Grad, sage ich sogar, Beleidigung aushalten, als als normaler Mensch.
Das kann nicht sein, dass da irgendwie einer ein abgewandeltes Schwarzkopf-Logo postet und dann steht die Polizei in der Tür.
Und das sollte jeden interessieren, auch die Leute, die sagen, ja, ist doch gut, betrifft ja jetzt die Richtigen.
Also das ist so ein Ding, gerade auf Twitter habe ich den Eindruck, die Leute feiern solche Sachen richtig, solange es eben Leute betrifft, die sie nicht leiden können.
Es ist ja auch einfach zu sagen,
guck mal hier, der hat eine andere Ansicht wie ich,
der ist vielleicht aus einem anderen politischen Lager wie ich.
Wenn es den trifft, ist doch gut.
Die Leute denken sich, mir passiert das ja nicht,
weil ich gehöre zu den Guten.
Was meint ihr, wie schnell sich der Wind drehen kann,
wer jetzt zu den Guten gehört?
Wartet mal ab, wie es in zwei, drei Jahren aussieht.
Und wartet mal ab, und das ist auch wieder so ein Punkt,
Von wegen, es ist von Nachteil, wenn das mitgelesen werden kann, was jemand schreibt im Internet. Ihr könnt heute was posten, was vollkommen, sagen wir mal, akzeptiert ist, wo euch nichts, keiner einen Strick draus drehen kann.
Wartet mal ab in fünf Jahren, wenn sich die Machtverhältnisse und alles komplett geändert haben.
Und dann krebt einer einen Post von euch aus, von vor fünf Jahren, den man auf euch zurückverfolgen kann.
Und ihr habt vor fünf Jahren was gesagt, was in der heutigen Zeit überhaupt nicht mehr in das aktuelle Bild reinpasst.
Und das passiert ja. Das passiert ja jetzt schon.
Es werden ja jetzt schon Twitter-Accounts von Leuten auseinandergenommen, weil sie vor elf Jahren irgendwas gepostet haben, um sich dann daran hochzuziehen, was für ein schlechter Mensch sie sind. Das passiert ja jetzt schon. Leute haben vor elf Jahren was gepostet, dann gibt es Verrückte, die nehmen das und rufen den Arbeitgeber von den Leuten an und sagen, wussten sie, dass ihr Mitarbeiter vor elf Jahren mal irgendwas gepostet hat.
ja also das
ist auch wieder so ein Ding, wo es halt fraglich ist
ist das wirklich
ist das denn so toll, nur weil es jetzt
aus aktueller Sicht die richtigen trifft
tja
ja und ich glaube
da machen sich viel zu wenig Leute Gedanken drüber
in welche Richtung sich das alles entwickelt
Ja, das kommt dann raus, genau.
Ich gucke mir Rule 34 C++ an.
Oh Gott, ich will nicht danach suchen, Leute.
Das gibt es bestimmt.
Fuck, jetzt habe ich eine blöde Idee gehabt.
Moment, Moment.
Ich muss mal auf dem zweiten Bildschirm kurz was gucken.
Okay, okay, ich hab glücklicherweise
nichts gefunden dazu auf den ersten Blick
Aber mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn es da sogar
C++-Fetisch-Leute gibt
Ja, ja, genau, genau.
Es gibt mehrere solcher Beispiele.
Ja, es gibt mehrere solcher Beispiele.
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt auch ein sehr provozierendes Foto, ja, aber trotzdem, es gibt mehrere solcher Beispiele.
Guck mal, und bei dem ist, also den Fall hier kannte ich jetzt noch nicht, aber entscheidend war es hier auch so.
Zwei Jahre später kam die Polizei zur Hausdurchsuchung, es steht, ja, weil er das gepostet hat.
Ach, über dem Bild steht das, okay.
Okay. Tja, seht ihr mal. Das, ne? Kann immer ganz schnell passieren in Deutschland.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal das Video weiter.
Ich finde das Wort, das ist eh so ein Wort, für mich eines der Worte 2026, Einordnung.
Du kannst heutzutage, hast du zumindest den Eindruck, wenn du dir manche Leute anhörst,
Du darfst dir heutzutage keinerlei Content mehr anschauen, ohne dass du dir danach noch eine Einordnung des Contents anschaust. Es ist, als wären die Leute nicht mehr in der Lage, irgendwie selbst im Kopf zu sagen, ah, das ist Blödsinn, ah, da könnte was dran sein. Du musst dir Content angucken und danach am besten noch von irgendwie einer offiziell zertifizierten Stelle, das muss eingeordnet sein.
und ich werde jetzt gar nicht bestreiten
dass es tatsächlich bei vielen
ja, bei vielen Leuten
vielleicht gar nicht verkehrt wäre
aber es geht ja nicht darum, die Leute zu bevormunden
ja und dass
viele Leute nichts im Hirn haben und
Scheiße glauben, ist halt so
damit muss man leben
Na, wenn du strafbare Sachen ins Internet postest,
da hast du ja jetzt schon Probleme.
Also, sehe ich jetzt keinen Unterschied zu früher, ja.
Das Problem bei den...
Also zum Beispiel das Problem damals, was diese Schwarzkopf-Geschichte bei Habeck angeht, war ja, nicht, dass es strafbar war, was der Typ gepostet hat, da drüber, sondern dass man mit der Hausdurchsuchung ihn bestrafen wollte.
Das war ja das Problem an der Sache.
es ging nicht darum
irgendwie
Beweise zu sichern oder
es ging darum, ihn zu bestrafen, weil er
was Falsches gepostet hat
und dafür ist eine Hausdurchsuchung nicht da
wenn einer
strafbare Sachen
im Internet postet, dann muss er
auch damit rechnen, dass das verfolgt wird
und das ist
ja auch schon immer so gewesen
Es ist dieses ganze Gelaber von, das Internet darf kein rechtsfreier Raum sein, das ist Blödsinn, das Internet war noch nie rechtsfreier Raum. Und unterm Strich, und das kann man zum Schluss sagen, unterm Strich ist es immer, ist es immer ein Abwägen zwischen Freiheit und Kontrolle.
Ja, ist so. Deswegen kann man da auch keine harte Linie ziehen. Weil wenn du eine harte Linie ziehst, musst du sagen, okay, es muss alles kontrolliert werden oder es muss nichts kontrolliert werden. Die Linie verläuft unscharf.
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen, auf welche Mist das gewachsen ist,
aber es gab ja,
gab es nicht danach
sogar irgendwelche, ich weiß nicht,
ob das das war, irgendwelche Protokolle,
wo die sich
sogar gefreut haben, dass man
den Leuten mit einer Hausdurchsuchung
eins reingewirkt hat?
also das ist schon echt fragwürdig
ja oder oder wo es letztens probleme gab weil einer was mit märz und lange nase
und so gepostet hat das kann nicht sein also ich bin der meinung politiker
müssen sogar noch mehr aushalten als normale leute
also schon krass
Ich will jetzt, du kannst danach googeln, ich will jetzt nicht danach suchen, weil das sonst ausartet.
Aber ich glaube, wir können uns darauf einigen, dass eine Hausdurchsuchung
wegen das Posten eines veränderten Schwarzkopf-Fotos etwas übertrieben ist.
Ich kann ja sogar verstehen, dass er beleidigt ist. Soll er beleidigt sein? Ist ja auch in Ordnung.
Ja, das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Es verläuft unscharf.
Also ich denke mal, sobald es in Richtung Morddrohungen und sowas geht, das ist auf jeden Fall illegal und sollte verfolgt werden.
Beleidigung von Frau, Kindern, irgendwelche super krassen Dinge, das finde ich muss man nicht aushalten.
Aber so Sachen wie Merz mit einer langen Nase und es kann sein, es wäre gut, wenn das mittlerweile so ist.
Aber trotzdem, trotzdem muss man sagen, die Hausdurchsuchung war mehr Bestrafung als die eigentliche Sache an sich. Eine Hausdurchsuchung ist in dem Fall ja, wenn du sagst, okay, was könnte im schlimmsten Fall passieren? Ja gut, Beleidigung, du kriegst im schlimmsten Fall ein bisschen Bußgeld oder was auch immer.
da ist die Hausdurchsuchung
komplett unverhältnismäßig.
Und es ist gut, dass das mittlerweile, wenn das in dem
Fall so ist, weiß ich nicht, ein Gericht bestätigt
hat, aber trotzdem hat man ihn bestraft
mit einer Hausdurchsuchung.
Also das ist total übers Ziel hinausgeschossen.
Also das ist teilweise echt krass.
Ja, aber ich denke, Sachen, die sich noch... Wie kann man da die Grenze ziehen? Schwierig. Das ist halt so ein Ding, das ist halt so eine Sache, was gesellschaftlich ausgehandelt werden muss, bis wann das noch okay ist.
Aber ich finde, es ist nicht okay, dass sich überhaupt Polizei und Gerichte und Leute damit beschäftigen müssen, wenn es um diese Geschichte mit merzlanger Nase oder Schwarzkopfbild geht. Das ist komplett unverhältnismäßig.
Naja, es hätte ja auch durchaus
es hätte ja auch durchaus
der Richter sagen können, für diese
Lappalie machen wir keine Hausdurchsuchung
dafür sind die ja da
und das an der Stelle zu entscheiden und zu sagen
ey, guck mal, das ist kompletter Blödsinn
also da hat man ordentlich verkackt
also schwierig, kann man so nicht sagen
bis wann es okay ist
Ich denke mal, solange sich das im satirischen Rahmen bewegt, solange das jetzt keine niedrigste Beleidigungsdinger sind, also ich bin der Meinung, es muss sich keiner anhören, dass er ein Hurensohn ist oder sowas.
Das muss nicht unbedingt sein, wenn jetzt einer ein Bild postet von, keine Ahnung, dem Paulanergarten und macht ein Bild.
Stellt euch mal vor, so Geschichten aus dem Paulanergarten.
Wenn jetzt einer sich einen Politiker nimmt und ihn photoshoppt in Paulanergarten und schreibt darüber Geschichten aus dem Paulanergarten.
Das ist halt was, damit musst du klarkommen.
Und selbst wenn es ein bisschen härter wird in den Vergleichen und so, dann musst du damit auch klarkommen.
Wenn es dann in den illegalen Bereich geht, ja, von Verwenden von irgendwelchen verfassungsfeindlichen Symbolen oder sowas in den Bildern, ja, dann ist es keine Frage.
Dann ist das ja aber auch wirklich eindeutig illegal. Und dann kann man da auch sagen, okay, das wird jetzt verfolgt.
Aber diese ganzen oberflächlichen Dinger
Wen juckt's?
Das musst du aushalten
Was ich mich schon für eine Scheiße unter meinen Videos
Durchlesen musste
Und ich hab noch nie irgendjemand angezeigt
Und da waren Dinger drin
Die waren sicherlich
Schlimmer als
Schwarzkopf und lange Nase und sowas
Da waren teilweise
Dinger dabei
Wo du es dir wirklich aufs Übelste beleidigst
Ich habe nie irgendjemand angezeigt dafür.
Weil ich denke mir einfach, okay, ich mache öffentlich Videos an der Stelle.
Da kann man es bis zum gewissen Grad schon ertragen, dass es halt Leute gibt, die einfach dumm sind, es nicht checken oder was auch immer.
Oder es überhaupt nicht so sehen und sich dann beleidigen.
Ich freue mich da sicherlich nicht drüber.
Ich banne dann manchmal die Leute auch einfach.
Ich war ja früher auch komplett anti-bannen.
Ich hab das erste Jahr auf YouTube niemand gebannt, weil ich mir gedacht hab, es soll jeder sagen können, was er will. Aber da war halt so viel dummes Zeug dabei, bis ich dann irgendwann drauf gekommen bin und hab gesagt, ey, YouTube ist hier nicht Demokratie, wo jeder abstimmen darf, sondern da hab ich das Sagen. Und Sachen, die mir nicht gefallen haben, die auch schon unter die Gürtellinie gingen, hab ich dann auch gebannt und gelöscht.
aber ich habe mir so viel scheiße da durchlesen müssen unter youtube videos teilweise sogar hier
im chat war ja scheinbar schon richtig letztens hat irgendjemand geschrieben im chat sinngemäß
ich krieg ich krieg's jetzt gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen das war es war irgendwas das war etwas
in richtung du stirbst oder so ja der ist in den stream gekommen hat das bild hier gesehen
mit Chico und meiner Katze.
Da hat er irgendwie gesagt, ich hoffe,
du und deine Katze ihr verreckt oder sowas.
Irgendwas in der Richtung.
Hat letzten Satz noch gar nicht so lange her.
Ein paar Wochen geschrieben.
Ja, ey, so what?
Ich freue mich nicht über so Kommentare,
aber ich banne ihn dann und gut ist.
Zeige ich den jetzt deswegen an,
weil er mal was geschrieben hat
in einem Twitch-Chat? Nee.
Ja, wenn jetzt einer schreiben würde, ey Max, morgen lauer ich dich auf, bring deine Haustiere dich, deine Mutter, deinen Vater und alles um und brenn dein Haus nieder, dann würde ich den anzeigen.
Da reden wir ja schon mal von einem bisschen anderen Schweregrad.
Das wäre dann schon was anderes, wenn wir sagen, okay, da ist eindeutig eine Linie überschritten, das muss nicht sein.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir mal das Video zum Glasfaserausbau.
Wo sind wir denn eigentlich stehen geblieben bei diesem Video?
Das DSL suckt gerade für so eine Agentur, ja.
Videokonferenzen, Cloud-Diensten oder Datensicherung.
Das Ziel, die komplette Umrüstung des Netzes auf Glasfaser. Doch Deutschland hinkt beim Ausbau hinterher.
Der Druck ist aus mehreren Gründen inzwischen immens. Europa guckt auf Deutschland.
Deutschland guckt ein wenig neidisch auf andere Länder und wir spüren aus Brüssel schon die klare Erwartung, Deutschland möge schneller werden.
Das wäre mir mal scheißegal, was wir aus Brüssel spüren. Das sollten wir von uns aus spüren.
WTF? Warum muss das irgendwo aus Brüssel einer spüren, dass man da Erwartungen hat?
Warum kann man nicht sagen, Alter, okay, zeitgemäße Technik, um ins Internet zu kommen,
ist 2026, einfach sollte gegeben sein.
Eine Statistik des Europäischen Glasfaserverbands vom September letzten Jahres
weist den Anteil der Gebäude aus, bei denen Glasfaser in der Straße liegt
und für die ein Anschluss möglich wäre.
Während andere Flächenländer wie Rumänien, Spanien, Portugal oder Frankreich ihre Netze fast komplett modernisiert haben, liegt doch...
Wir hatten halt CDU-Stells am Start, die gesagt haben, ey, Kupferbässe.
Ja, die Oma kann das ja auch weiter sagen.
Man kann ja gar nicht von der Oma erwarten, dass sie da den Durchblick hat.
Die Oma würde allerdings genauso einen Glasfaseranschluss nehmen mit einem günstigen Tarif.
Da hat die Oma halt nur 250, 50, meinetwegen auch über Glasfaser.
Ländervergleiche hinken, das stimmt.
Es kommt immer ganz auf die Geografie und die Einwohneranzahl und wie das sonst so ist drumherum.
Aber man kann schon sagen, als Land mit der drittgrößten Wirtschaft der Welt könnte man ein bisschen mehr ausgebaut haben als wir.
Deutschland deutlich unter dem europäischen Durchschnitt.
Gebaut wird inzwischen fast überall eines der größten Infrastrukturprojekte Deutschlands.
Wir müssen ganz Deutschland letztlich mit Glasfaserleitungen verkabeln.
Und da sprechen wir noch über Investitionen in zweistelliger Milliardenhöhe.
Das heißt, es muss noch sehr viel gebuddelt und sehr viel investiert werden,
bis wir in Deutschland einen flächendeckenden Glasfaserausbau haben werden.
Vor allem der Tiefbau ist aufwendig und wird immer teurer, wenn der Bau denn starten kann.
Die Ausbaukosten sind in den letzten Jahren massiv angestiegen.
Wir reden über Kostensteigerungen von allein im Tiefbau von 40 Prozent in den letzten fünf Jahren.
Ein weiteres Thema, was immer wieder auftaucht, sind langwierige, oftmals noch analoge Genehmigungsverfahren.
Hürden abbauen und mehr Tempo, das verspricht das neue Telekommunikationsgesetz, das Digitalminister Wildberger derzeit vorbereitet.
Es könnte auch die Rolle der Bundesnetzagentur stärken, die bislang nur wenig Druck auf die Glasfaseranbieter ausüben kann.
Haben wir nicht.
Mittlerweile,
vor ein paar Jahren,
hatten wir doch so einen,
wie nannten, wie haben sie das genannt?
Das
Faser Offensive, oder was?
Ich hab da doch auch ein Video zu gemacht.
Moment.
Internet.
Nein, nein, das nicht.
Internet-Deutsche auch 2021 noch Neuland
Warum ist das Internet in Deutschland so langsam?
Einig das? Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das Video meine
Da gab es doch jetzt so einen, ich habe das schon wieder vergessen, ja.
Da gab es doch so einen Breitbandatlas. Es sollte damals eine zentrale Stelle geben, wo der Ausbau dokumentiert wird mit wo ist, wo geplant ist, wo gelegt werden soll, so dass man schnell nachvollziehen kann, wo es stockt, um dann gegenzusteuern.
Das habe ich irgendwo in dem Video auch erzählt, ja.
Zumindest, was ist denn damit jetzt eigentlich geworden?
Denn moderne Netze entscheiden darüber, wie zuverlässig Unternehmen arbeiten können
und wie attraktiv Deutschland als Standort bleibt.
Anwendungen rund um Cloud-Dienste, KI oder IT-Sicherheit treiben die Datenmenge nach oben.
Mittelständler wie BPI6 sind angewiesen auf die stabile, verlustfreie Übertragung via Glasfaser.
Wenn das ausfällt, haben wir tatsächlich ein Problem, weil wir nicht mehr miteinander zusammenarbeiten können,
weil wir auf unsere Daten nicht zugreifen können, die in der Cloud liegen.
Unsere Mitarbeiter sind in dem Moment von uns abgeschnitten.
Ohne die stabile Leitung geht heutzutage bei uns nichts.
Je digitaler Unternehmen arbeiten, desto sichtbarer werden die Schwächen der bestehenden Netze.
Das Ziel früherer Regierungen, flächendeckend Glasfaser bis 2030, wird deutlich verfehlt.
Bis 2035 oder noch länger dürfte der Ausbau andauern.
Tja, wenn auch schleppend der Glasfaserausbau läuft also und wird auch für private Haushalte angeboten.
Wenn Vertriebsmitarbeiter an ihrer Türe klingeln und sie...
Ah, Ranger!
Chatgear, hattet ihr die auch schon mal?
Hatte ich auch schon mal Ranger an der Türe?
Ranger Marketing von der Telekom.
Zum Unterschreiben drängen, lassen Sie sich nicht unter Druck setzen.
Auch nicht, wenn es heißt, bald haben Sie kein Internet mehr oder kostenlos ist der Anschluss nur heute.
Nehmen Sie sich die Zeit und informieren Sie sich über Kosten und Verträge.
Generell kann der Umstieg auf Glasfaser nämlich auch für Privathaushalte sinnvoll sein.
Hier werden gerade im großen Stil Leitungen für Glasfaseranschlüsse gelegt.
Der komplette Stadtteil von Frankfurt am Main mit 4000 Haushalten bekommt die neuen Anschlüsse.
Der Weg zu schnellerem Internet.
Ob sich die Kunden am Ende auch für Glasfaser entscheiden, ist noch offen.
Die Anbieter werden massiv dafür.
Man kennt das aus dem eigenen Haushalt. Die Fernsehbilder, die Videos werden immer hochauflösender, auch die Fotos werden immer hochauflösender. Dort entstehen immer größere Datenmengen. Von daher braucht man auch eine Infrastruktur.
Ja, ach, das ist jetzt aber keine neue Erkenntnis aus 2026, oder?
Bewegen kann mit Glasfaser, ist das möglich?
Für die Anbieter ist der Umstieg aufwendig und teuer.
80.000 Euro kostet im Schnitt der Kilometer Glasfaser.
In der Regel bauen sie daher nur dort aus, wo sich genügend Haushalte vorab für einen Anschluss entscheiden.
Der klare Rat des Verbraucherschützers?
Grundsätzlich empfehlen wir, beim Erstausbau mit dabei zu sein und einen Vertrag abzuschließen.
Es ist meistens kostengünstiger, weil die Glasfaserunternehmen so ein bisschen den Deal haben.
Wir erlassen dem Kunden die Tiefbaukosten.
Also Leute, ich sage euch, ich sage euch wie es ist.
Sobald ich die Möglichkeit habe, dass hier Glasfaser ausgebaut wird, ich bin instant der Erste, der ausbaut.
Ich bagger denen sogar selbst die Straße auf, wenn die wollen.
Aber dafür muss man halt den Glasfaseranschluss zwei Jahre benutzen.
Wenn man später dann halt bei sich anschließen lassen würde, dann kämen halt höhere Tiefbaukosten auf einen zu.
Die Glasfaseranbieter haben derzeit ein Problem.
Sie bauen für eine große Kundennachfrage aus, doch nur wenige Haushalte nutzen die Gelegenheit für den Umstieg.
Konkret, deutschlandweit könnten 53% der Anschlüsse und 24 Millionen auch Glasfaser bekommen.
Aber nur 6,6 Millionen Kunden haben einen entsprechenden Tarif gewählt.
Das ist gerade mal etwa jeder Vierte, der Glasfaser buchen könnte.
Damit Glasfaser ins Haus kommt, muss gebaggert und gebaut werden.
In Mehrfamilienhaus oft nach zusätzlicher Verkabelung und mit Zustimmung der Eigentümer.
Bei aller Technik gilt aber auch, Verträge sollte man genau prüfen. Viele Glasfaser anbieten.
Ansonsten sind wir doch immer so erpicht drauf, Dinger zu regeln, zu verbieten, zu machen und zu tun.
Da könnte man doch jetzt auch echt sagen, du hast ein Recht auf einen Glasfaseranschluss. Bam!
Bieter setzen auf Vertrieb direkt an der Haustür und externe Verkäufer für die Verträge.
Verbraucherschützern gefällt das nicht.
Wir erleben es sehr oft, dass Verbraucher verunsichert kommen.
Die müssen ja nicht upgraden.
Die können ja auch langsam Kram über Glasfaser machen, wenn sie das wollen.
Ist doch vollkommen egal.
Wenn einer nicht 1000 Synchronen bezahlen will, soll er halt weniger bezahlen.
Wichtig ist, dass die Infrastruktur gelegt wird.
Und wenn er keinen Bock hat, sich sein Haus anschließen zu lassen,
soll er sich sein Haus halt nicht anschließen lassen.
Ist aber halt dumm.
Aber wichtig ist, dass die Infrastruktur gelegt wird.
Sagen, naja, der andere Haustür hat mir erzählt, wenn man jetzt den Glasfaservertrag nicht unterschreibt, dann steht man in zwei, drei Monaten ohne Internet.
Ja, die erzählen immer viel dummes Zeug.
Das sind natürlich alles in Anführungszeichen Märchen.
Generell sollte man sich einfach vielleicht bei dem Vertriebler Informationen holen und sich dann selbst im Internet schlau machen.
Die Glasfaser gilt als Technik der Zukunft, weil sie die steigenden Datenmengen stabil transportieren kann.
Bei DSL und Kabel ist in einigen Jahren die Grenze erreicht.
Der Ausbau geht voran. Wer die Chance hat, sollte über Glasfaser nachdenken.
Vielen Dank.
Okay
Schätke
Ich hab richtig brutal Hunger
Gestern 12,7 Kilometer gerannt
Heute muss ich nochmal
Aber nicht 12,5
Sondern wahrscheinlich
Ich glaub 46 Minuten
46 Minuten sind
8 oder so.
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
So in dem Dreh.
Ich habe noch einen Beitrag gefunden.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es da drin vorkommt,
wo es hier um...
Da ist doch gerade von...
...von Meinungsfreiheit im Internet
und Leute, die blöde Memes gepostet haben,
mit Hausdurchsuchung. Ich habe jetzt nur noch das
gefunden, wo es damals riesen Aufriss
gab hier.
Da gab es eine Reportage über
Meinungsfreiheit in Deutschland.
Und in dieser Reportage,
wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf habe,
wurde, glaube ich,
ein Richter oder ein Staatsanwalt
interviewt.
Und
die haben sich dann richtig drüber gefreut,
dass sie dem quasi jetzt
eine Hausdurchsuchung reindrücken können.
So als Bestrafung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das da drinnen vorkommt hier.
Die Meinungsfreiheit hier in Deutschland, die ist ja im Grundgesetz verankert und ein kritischer...
Aber da müssen wir sich mal durchlegen, weil das ist wirklich komplett das Unding.
... ist dann das CBS über die Arbeit deutscher Staatsanwälte, der sorgt nun in dieser Frage nicht nur hier in Deutschland...
Mal gucken, ob da jetzt was Sinnvolles drin ist.
... für Aufsehen. US-Vizepräsident J.D. Vance, der sieht sich sogar...
Ja gut, der Typ erzählt viel, wenn er nach Lange ist.
... jetzt schon in seiner Kritik an Deutschland bestätigt.
Reporter des erfolgreichen und anerkannten Formates 60 Minutes begleiteten und befragten nämlich drei Staatsanwälte
von der Zentralstelle zur Bekämpfung von Hasskriminalität im Internet Niedersachsen.
Sie waren live mit dabei, als Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft frühmorgens Wohnungen durchsuchten
und Handys sowie Laptops beschlagnahmten.
Wie reagieren die Menschen, wenn ihnen das Handy weggenommen wird, fragt die Reporterin.
Die Antwort, sie sind geschockt, sagt ein Oberstaatsanwalt
und bricht gemeinsam mit seinen Kollegen in Gelächter aus.
Daraufhin schrieb J.D. Vance auf X.
Äh, da hätten wir jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr zum Inhalt noch sagen können.
Jemanden zu beleidigen ist kein Verbrechen und die Kriminalisierung...
Die Amis, die sehen das nochmal eh komplett anders.
... von Äußerungen, wird die Beziehungen zwischen Europa und den USA...
Ja, bla bla bla bla.
Nee, dann war das doch jetzt nicht so geil, was die hier in dem Beitrag erzählt haben.
Aber ihr müsst euch das mal angucken.
Also, wenn man wirklich so Dinge hört, wie man drückt dir eine Hausdurchsuchung als Bestrafung rein,
das ist auch komplett unzulässig.
Also, das darf nicht dafür benutzt werden, um Leute zu bestrafen.
Das ist teilweise echt krass, was abgeht in der Richtung.
So, dann gehe ich jetzt was futtern.
Und...
Wir hören uns.
Vielleicht machen wir Set-Servers fertig heute Abend.
Ich glaube, wir machen Set-Servers mal weiter.
Wird Zeit.
Macht's gut. Ich geh jetzt was futtern.
Ich hab mega Hunger. Bis dann.
See you.